wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn how to structure our portfolio
that pays you $50,000 per year how to
overcome your fear of investing the
simple steps to make money work for you
on autopilot and how to legally cut your
taxes by 20% get ready for a wealth
building Journey today is dedicated to
turning your dreams into opportunities
for financial success
enjoy hello and welcome to wealth
breakthroughs episode 6 I'm Patrick
gentempo author speaker investor and
entrepreneur Andy Tanner's life is about
pure hustle he's energetic and engaging
and our interview could have gone on for
hours and hours in today's first
interview he's going to show you how to
build a profitable Investment Portfolio
no matter how much money you have to
begin four steps hold all the magic
follow Andy's instructions and you have
a readymade wealth breakthrough he'll
show you how to structure a portfolio so
it eventually pays you as much as $40 or
$50,000 or more a year in dividends
there's no sense in holding back let's
get started
[Music]
Andy very much looking forward to this
conversation uh so great to be here
thanks for having me so tell us a little
bit about your background what got you
into doing the work you're doing today
well uh growing up I was one of those
lost kids that didn't know what they
wanted to do uh grown-ups tell you to
get good grades find that job and I I
never really found my my uh way there MH
I uh I'm a big guy so luckily I could uh
I could foul well enough to make a
basketball team you how tall are you I'm
about 68 wow yeah say you walk in it's
like you look up I don't tell people
much I weigh
anymore so but that was about 100 pounds
ago so but it was uh it was interesting
cuz when all that was finished and done
I really didn't know what I wanted to do
and I found myself in sales I got really
good at sales and business and I you
know learned how to how to pitch things
so to speak and I ran into a company
that was selling a software on trading
and uh you know the internet had just
come about and I got really interested
in that and as a result I started using
it started learning about it and moved
away uh from there into being an
educator and investor so uh you know
things just worked out and and landed in
a really nice place so So when you say
an educator and an investor uh obviously
you do your own investing but you also
are educating other people on how to do
it uh so the education part came um a
because it's something I very much enjoy
and as I got to know more and more
teachers and mentors they were kind
enough to ask me to join some of the
things they were doing I've been a rich
dad advisor for Robert and Kim Kaki for
oh 10 12 years now and that's just been
a wonderful adventure learning from them
and then passing on the things I've
learned from my mentors and also uh
experience both good and bad how
important is the mentor in the process
of becoming a good investor I I think
it's everything if you look at the
greatest investor in the world Warren
Buffett you look behind him and Benjamin
Graham is right there um Robert had a
rich dad almost every great investor I
can think of had someone that taught
them how this worked and so I don't
think there's any guarantees when you
invest but having a a great mentor uh to
talk to to question to guide you um
that's really what the book Rich Dad
Poor Dad was all about was a a book
about having Rich Dad a mentor and I
guess you on the flip side having the
wrong guidance or let's call them the
the anti- uh
Mentor somebody's mentoring you but
giving you bad advice that can also send
you in the wrong direction sometimes
that's trial and error you know you take
a punch and say well I shouldn't
listened to to this guy but that's a
huge point you make though about
mentorship you know when as a richat
advisor I get asked a lot about Robert
and Kim and and You Know Rich Dad Poor
Dad and that whole series of books and I
remember I ran into it like anybody else
uh a friend of mine gave it to me in the
90s and I read it and we thought it was
about buying assets you know we said
well we'll stop buying liabilities and
we'll go buy assets and we set out to
buy real estate my wife and I we bought
zero real estate I mean we you know once
we got in the details of it we were
unsure and the fog of concern came in
and I remember she said let's reread
this book and see what we missed so we
sat down to read it and she looked at
the cover and said I got it I said what
do you mean I got it she said hey we've
both got poor dads we halfway there all
we need is the rich dad and when we made
that
transition from searching for deals to
searching for people that could help us
that made a huge difference so I I can't
say enough about
the importance of of working as a team
and finding the right teachers that's
actually pretty fascinating uh you know
that you had that realization because a
lot of times people think it's you know
maybe just Add Water okay here's the
advice this you do this you do this you
do this and I think having a process you
know a template to work for them is a
good thing but uh you stopped and said I
got to go find a mentor so how do you go
and find a good Mentor I think uh when
you look at advisors and mentors they're
very similar advisers like accounts and
attorneys uh I think you talk to the
people who do what you'd like to do and
then ask them you know who their
advisors or mentors were that's I think
the most Surefire way through a network
or someone that you know and trust when
they recommend someone that's a good
sign if someone's successful says you
know forign Buffett says yeah I read
Benjamin Graham's book he was my great
mentor that's a clue yeah that's a clue
for sure that's great so what's your
philosophy on investing how do how do
you like approach it from maybe the the
high level saying this is the way I see
things sure investing is about uh
investing wisely in in making
transactions and this is not something
that that we have in school you know we
have economics and finance but investing
is different and when uh when Robert
asked me to write my book in his series
it forced me to answer that question
what what is investing and I've come to
believe that there's four
things uh that make up that make up
investing or at least a wise investor
the first two have to do with gathering
information um for jargon and and fancy
terms we call this understanding things
fundamentally or what you call a
fundamental analysis so the first
lessons of investing I would say is the
ability to look at a deal and understand
its numbers you know can I look at uh a
church and is it doing well can I look
at a nonprofit a government a stock or
real estate deal when I look at its
income and its its expenses its assets
its liabilities when I look at those
numbers do I understand them well enough
to say well at least it's you know
surviving now at least it's headed in
the right direction so that'd be the
first one the second thing I would say
of the four is also information
gathering we have to be aware of Trends
M uh trending is a huge thing in
business business we don't want to react
too much to every little blip that
that'd be silly but understand the
general idea of supply and demand and
where things are headed uh is a huge
Advantage so with those two things we
have information the third thing is
critical is that's where we begin to
take some action in how we position
ourselves for example uh not much I can
do about a report that comes out on a on
a particular stock that the numbers are
what they are but I can choose how I
position myself whether I'm long or
short or want a cash flow or how I want
to place my money in the in the way of
success so to speak and then the fourth
thing is is the one that I think is the
most important thing to learn in
investing and that's the idea of
managing risk um those numbers people
think it's about predicting the future
and I tend to think less so I I think
Trends are important but dealing with
Sudden Change when you can do that uh
then you can invest with confidence
knowing you have a plan B that's the you
know we spoke last time about 401ks and
that that lack of a plan B bothers me
the most is is you know if you have a
systemic issue what are you going to do
so having a plan B and knowing how to
adjust so those are the four looking at
numbers fundamentals um looking at
Trends some people call it technicals uh
positioning yourself for cash flow and
then finally risk management and then
nutshell those are the four things I
think about when I'm going to make an
investment decision can you give me an
example of uh what you mean by a plan B
absolutely uh insurance is a good plan B
and the stock market we call that a
hedge and the idea is if we you know you
would never never put money in a home
without insurance because it could burn
down now you and I uh we don't think our
house is going to burn down today we
don't think it's likely we were not
predicting that would burn down right
and yet if it did uh no one would claim
that we're Geniuses because we bought
Insurance well a more specific example
that I often cite is Mark Cuban MH I
don't remember if we talked about this
before but even so it Bears repeating is
Mark Cuban had a company called
broadcast.com you know broadcast
baseball games all over the world the
internet was brand new and sexy and a
company search engine Yahoo came to him
MH and said we'll give you you know $6
billion of Yahoo stock for this company
and he said yes and uh and that was
around oh was probably $100 a share
within a very short amount of time it's
worth $5 MH and yet Cuban still owns the
Mavericks and is Rich and and he was on
60 Minutes with Steve Croft and Croft
says how'd you do it you know I mean you
you trade all your money for this stock
and it goes to zero how come you're
still billionaire and he said well I was
covered I was hedged in other words he
had purchased some contracts uh that
were very much like insurance contracts
that allowed him to sell at a high price
even though it it came down low and
Steve crop says well he was a genius I
says well not really because if he
thought it was going to go down he would
have sold for cash instead of stock the
only reason you sell for stocks if you
thought it was going up but the fact he
had Insurance made him look smarter than
the average person but in reality he's
no smarter than you and I insuring a
home or a car so there's lots of
different plan BS there's Insurance
there's exits um there's position sizes
a lot of different ways to to manage
risk so furthering that scenario um what
percentage of the position let's say in
a in you're long on a stock what
percentage of that position would you be
spending on this type of insurance
you're talking about saying that you
know if it were to really fall that
you're you're protected yeah that's a
great question because insurance is
going to eat up profits no question that
if I'm a Speculator home and I Ure it uh
that it's going to it's going to eat up
some of those profits um a good example
would be the ratio you spend on a rental
home to ensure it so in the stock market
it's going to depend on the stock but
I'll give you a good example I might
have a position that is $100 a share MH
uh you could hedge that with a with a
decent Hedge for 5 cents uh 10 cents at
the most uh if you had if you were for
far enough out of the money so it really
depends on um the deductibles you want
to pay and the premiums you want to pay
but having something there y um I think
is a wise choice so in that scenario 5
to 10% of the total position value I'd
say much much less than that I'd say
maybe a half a percent I'm sorry I was
off by decimal point yes so so half a
percent to a percent which obviously not
a bad investment uh to protect a
downside and and the other thing is that
un like a uh I don't need to having a
plan is different one of the I I don't
like to compare asset classes because I
think it's unwise um there are people
who say oh you don't want to be in
business you know that's a terrible idea
you know most businesses fail say oh if
you're real estate you be unclogging
people's toilets and I don't think that
that uh you know guy like Kenny maroy or
Robert kosaki spends their time
unclogging toilets oh you don't want to
be in stocks cuz so volatile if you look
at those differences though with that
said one of the nice things that that
paper assets have like stocks and
options is they're extremely liquid mhm
so if I see a rental property and it
starts on fire I can't pound a a sign
that says you know fire sale hurry up I
can sell you I better have insurance in
place right but in stocks I can have a
plan to hedge without having hedged and
and if things start to heat up and start
to I can jump in very quickly and
protect myself most people don't know
how to do that and so I can be very
reactive very very quickly and we can
neutralize things almost immediately so
we might not make a lot of money we
might not lose a lot of money we can
always uh neutralize position it will so
it isn't like I have this formula where
I have to say well x amount of my
profits are going to go for protection
even having a plan and knowing how to
deal with a fire uh is a great insurance
so do you have a um a philosophy about
you know Investing For Cash Flow yes and
can you invest for cash flow in the
stock market absolutely all right walk
me through that okay well there's an
easy way in a a way that's a little more
complex let's talk about the easy way
first okay um I think the greatest
example we could start with would be the
greatest investor of all time that would
be Warren Buffett and why why do you
think he's the greatest investor all
time just based on his results that he's
created or what what makes that stat I I
think I could I'm I'm kind of biased
because I study him a lot so I'm I kind
of get a little star struck when I talk
about him but but number one you
mentioned his results I mean he he has
amassed a tremendous amount of wealth
he's given um as much to charity as
anyone I know ever on planet Earth I
don't know anyone that's given way more
money than he has his percent return has
been phenomenal throughout his life and
he's done it consistently for 60 years I
think the greatest thing I learned from
him is his temperament um he's got an
incredible temperament how important is
that to investing well it's everything
isn't it is it you know Robert kosaki
says it this way when intelligence or
when uh emotion goes up intelligence
Goes Down And if you and I look at our
own life you know when we've done things
we shouldn't have done chances are we we
got emotional other way Buffett says
this he says we like to be fearful when
other people are greedy MH and greedy
when other people are fearful mhm and
the ability to keep cool and as you look
at him historically you know the the US
Bank play that he made and the the
difference Investments he've made he's
been a cool cucumber and being able to
seize opportunity when everybody else's
hair's on fire yeah so temperament I
know when I've made mistakes yeah yeah
Buffett's more like the uh he's like the
the roulette wield dealer
he doesn't exclaim at a win or a loss
you know when when the roulette dealer
loses he doesn't say oh no let's shut it
down when he wins he doesn't exclaim he
just says keep it rolling boys we have a
system keep it rolling it's the gamble
that tends to exclaim and so uh but
Buffett is a cash flow guy people don't
realize this um if you look at he's the
largest owner of
Coca-Cola and what's fascinating about
Coca-Cola is he bought that he started
buying that in the 80s MH
uh I think his cost basis in those days
about three bucks mhm well his dividend
on that's about $150 now wow so that's
pretty good Roi that's pretty good cash
flow that he's earned and the secret of
that was cost
basis um he has Investments right now
that he's paid full price for Apple he's
a huge uh he's investing more in Amazon
but in apple you know that's a dividend
stock now that gets his attention so all
a dividend is is if you owned a business
uh you get a share in some of those
profits right and there's uh there's
ratios where you can see what percent of
the earnings go back in the dividend and
because Buffett buys at low prices his
cost basis is higher you know I don't
know what Coke would be today I mean if
you bought it at at today's price you're
not going to get near 50% on your money
right but the wise investor finds ways
to reduce cost basis there's opportunity
ities I probably shouldn't uh yell out
companies now but a good example right
now is if you were to look at the
analysts at craft Hines for example uh
they're saying run for your life you
know it's down half and and it used to
be in the 70s and now you know the sec's
investigating them and all this type
stuff and all the analysts are running
you know 6 months ago they all said buy
byy buy now they're saying sell sell
sell and if you look at that they were
telling you buy it when it's high and
now they're telling you to sell it when
it's low which is the opposite of what
Buffett does right so almost every
analyst that sell craft hind well
Buffett owns 23% of that thing wow or
something like that you know about a
fourth of it and they go you going to
sell it he goes no he goes why he goes
well I cash flow about $300 million a
year from the dividend and the funny
thing is his cost basis is higher than
what you and I can get it for right now
wow so it's interesting it is
interesting and and I think you know
what you're saying is a lot of this is
driven by emotion not necessarily so if
you got the cool cucumber over here
doing fundamental analysis and then he's
seeing these emotional people running
from stocks because of something in a
headline he's saying oh let me stay calm
and uh take advantage of the situation
and that's where he's getting greedy
when other people are scared for sure if
you took those four things I mentioned
if you looked at it fundamentally they
have some problems they have a lot of
debt that's their biggest problem got a
lot of debt and you know their sales on
on some of their brands are tough but
you're looking at you know Oscar Meyer
and A1 steak sauce and craft macaron and
cheese and I still think you're going to
see Hines ketchup on the table so we're
trying to look you know 10 years from
now this year they might have some bad
earnings you know we might be able to
pick that thing up at $15 maybe at some
point what how awesome would that be so
that temperament is when the price is
that low um the key is is I'm not scared
to jump in because I know how to to get
out if it goes lower mhm and so when all
those analysts say oh run run run run
run it's terrible the earnings are bad
everything you know the trend is down
everything's bad I say well I don't care
about throwing a bunch of money at that
because if I can get out of it and I
have insurance for it well if it drops a
little I lose this much but if it
recovers now I can have a lowc cost
basis like Buffett hat and Coke right so
you can't do that without all four
without knowing how to get out if it
doesn't work out but uh yeah Buffett's a
cash flow guy I mean he has he he brings
in what about $6 billion a year in
dividends simply from profit so if
you're a real estate investor you know I
have small amount of real estate nothing
like Robert has but you know I like that
income that comes from the profits well
stocks are the same right people buy a a
cocacola and I get a little bit of that
profit so do you buy mostly if not
exclusively dividend paying not at all I
I I very much you know Buffett has some
stocks that do not pay dividends as well
where he's looking for a probably growth
and then an I that someday they might go
from a grow stock to a dividend stock uh
for sure but the second way that I
really really enjoy is I love the
options market so let's talk about this
because this is risky business is this
the complicated side that yeah a little
bit more I would say I wouldn't say
Advanced but certainly intermediate so
think about this for a moment let's talk
about insurance MH do you want to be a
buyer insurance or seller of insurance
seller for sure right yeah Geico um
Buffett owns GEICO he he gets this
because what is Insurance well you're
basically uh calculating risk and making
sure that uh you're going to have a
profit at the end of the day after you
collect all the premium so so what are
your raw materials what are your
manufacturing costs your shiing cost
yeah it's a service it's a promise yeah
think about that I promise you I'll fix
your car if it wrecks mhm and you pay me
for that I promise you I'll fix your
house if it if it floods and you pay me
for that so if I'm smart certainly I'm
going to have some claims um if not it
wouldn't be value to the customer right
but think about that as long as the
premiums are greater than the amount of
claims it may be the world's perfect
business MH because there's nothing but
air there promises I have a little money
backing up that promise and that's it
there's nothing else to that business
well in the in the stock market there's
uh some wonderful
opportunities in that idea um except
when we get to keep the promises it's
almost good give you an example I
mentioned that Warren Buffett uh owns a
lot of
cocacola well a lot of people don't know
how he bought a lot of that coke what he
would do is he would make promises to
people that owned it um people that
would panic and say you know what if it
goes down I'll buy it from it
I'll give you that insurance policy cuz
here's the difference if I promise you
to pay you if your car wrecks and your
car wrecks well I'm out that money and
you know you keep your car but if I
promise you to buy your stock if it
falls and I keep that promise I now own
your stock so one of the things that a
very little known secret that Warren
Buffett will dabble in is he will sell
options as insurance and he'll say hey
if this thing comes down to a low level
and you're nervous about it I guarantee
you I'll buy that from you at a low
price and people pay him to do it and
they are they obligated to sell him
they're not they have an option they're
not obligated but here's what's
beautiful let's say the stock goes up
Warren keeps the premium say the stock
goes sideways Warren keeps the premium
say the stock goes down Warren keeps the
premium and he gets to buy the stock
lower than it was yesterday so in all
three scenarios he keeps the premium
right and when you work the numbers on
that um pretty nice um when you compare
it to other Investments the problem is
it's not for the uneducated MH if I
could communicate two things the first
thing is is you talked about the
importance of mentors we shouldn't leave
that idea ever that should we always
have one eye on that the other thing I
would say if if anyone's going to listen
to one thing I had to say is we have a
culture of advice mhm in other words
most of the people watching this
programmer hoping to get uh someone to
tell them what to do you know Andy
should I buy gold should I buy Bitcoin
should I buy real estate should I buy
oil should I buy stocks like you tell me
what stock to buy tell me what to do
there is very very very small amount of
people who are sincere and honest about
getting smarter mhm if I if I say go buy
gold you're not any smarter but if I say
gold is fungible now you're learning
things MH and so I I'm very passionate
about about drawing people to me um they
tend the people that that I tend to draw
are the people who want to get smarter
the people who want to learn how to fish
for real and don't get caught up in the
well here's a fish that'll make you a
million dollars and all that type of
thing so those are the two cash flows in
in stocks there's two great examples is
you can collect money for profits you
know dividends they divide the profits
up and you can sell an option um
insurance that allows you even buy more
or sell at a high price if you want and
those are two great examples of monthly
cash flow I was just this morning going
through some of my own Investments over
the years and you know adding up years
and years of Premium selling options I
was just showing my wife and it's
astounding how it adds up over the years
it's not going to be a venture where
someone exclaims and got rich quick
overnight it's a cash flow deal MH um
you know big turn ears big money cashow
is just nice and consistent and it grows
and that's where we like to hang out so
how much time do you have to spend to
personally manage the stuff you're doing
with options and and other Investments
me personally not much um generally the
way I do it is I have a a business
partner that I trade with and every
Monday before the Market opens we get
online together and have a way to you
know connect each other and we look at
our account together and we make the
major buys and sells um in the plan for
the week and that meeting takes us oh
usually anywhere from 30 to 90 minutes
depending on you know Market volatility
and certainly we have plans throughout
the week of all three directions if
something goes up this is what we'll do
something goes down this is what we'll
do something goes sideways this is what
we'll do and I'll tell you that gives
peace of mind because in reality we've
predicted the future think about that
for a minute we've predicted a future of
up down and sideways we got a plan for
each one so we rest easy yeah so when
people say Andy where do you think the
Market's going to go I says I don't know
for sure but I'm making a plan all three
way so I can sleep at night and so the
maintenance of that account is minimal
um you know if it doesn't move we're
fine if it goes up all those adjustments
are made now there are people who love
this uh to day trade and I don't you
know I get up in the morning load up
with coffee and go crazy all day but for
me a a good 90 you know 30 minute to 90
minute session on Monday uh seems to
work out real well for us how much money
does someone need to be able to start
this processing yeah want go into the
market um I'll spend my time you say
getting smarter maybe I'll learn about
options and figure out how to how to
trade those it's a fair question and
then uh and then you know or maybe I
just want to start buying some some
stocks uh some people might say well
I've only got $220,000 I don't think I
have enough money to to make anything
worthwhile out of this so I I've been
interviewed often but one of the things
I was taught they say don't answer the
question you're asked answer the one you
wished you were asked okay so I'll flip
that just a bit someone might say Andy
what would be the ideal amount okay and
uh the ideal amount would be about $20
billion so that'd be ni and uh and the
reality is is you you pretty much got to
start where you are right MH so whatever
amount you have is what you have
regardless what the ideal amount would
be now to answer your original question
most brokerages like to see person come
with a couple of thousand dollar to
start with and get you margin account
without education that can get you in
trouble right uh summer as low as 500
and a lot of them will let you just sign
up for account and let you practice on
paper till you get good at it which I
think is uh the best amount to start
with with me and my students like if
someone say Andy I want to be one of
your students I'd say well the amount
you're going to start with is zero mhm
and the reason is is I don't allow any
of my students to trade real money until
they practice on paper for quite a while
cuz what I believe is that if a person
learns to do this on paper with zero
money and all of a sudden they see some
results oh money comes out of the
woodwork because a lot of those
liabilities and dads they used to buy
they realize hey I'm losing money when I
you know put that new deck on the back
of my house or I'm losing money when I
go out and buy those designer shoes or
I'm losing because I could have been
putting it here right and having it grow
so the short answer couple of thousand
dolls the B best answer zero start
risk-free it doesn't make any sense to
start with money at risk and again the
advised people will say well I just want
to go make money but the education
people will say I get that that's smart
I'm going to learn with no risk and are
you buying and holding for extended
periods I mean what what's the time
Horizon obviously you don't want day
trade you that's that's like crazy yeah
uh Crazy Land and uh it's not what I
like to do yeah yeah so uh but do you
like to have points where you want to
exit a stock once you make a certain
amount or is it something you say you
know that's a dividend paying stock I'm
going to just keep trying to improve my
position in it uh how do you approach
that when I look at a uh a stock you
want to decide whether you want to have
cash flow or Capal gain opportunity I
like both M um there are a lot of times
where I say I think I can get a good
cost basis on this and I think this is a
stock I could you know sell covered
calls on and you know grow that over
time and hold on to it as long as I
don't get called out I'm fine MH um and
if I do I can hop back in so there's
some Nuance to that but I I love to have
a smaller amount of money and trade
opportunistically M I also uh like to
short the market uh okay so that's a
great example of uh a stock I've been
short and I hate to throw these out
because then people go out and copy it
and you know well they're watching yeah
they're watching this at different time
than we're recording it so yeah so but
uh I just uh I just got out of a short
on GameStop which is which was very very
profitable for us because GameStop
fundamentally is struggled mhm um they
remind me of Blockbuster trying to
compete with Netflix um the idea of
going into a retail store with a
downloadable digital thing I think it's
Antiquated and so I I that's not a cash
flow deal is it no and so uh we uh you
know we bought a bunch of put options on
that took a a bearish position and you
know got lucky we get lucky once in a
while so if if I see an opportunity like
that I I'll throw some money at that uh
for sure MH learning how to
short might be one of the smartest
things anyone whether they're whether
they're investing in real estate
business stocks or Commodities learning
how to short can be a very intelligent
thing
because if I were to tell you to
find this is an interesting conversation
actually if I were to tell you to find
Steve Jobs when he was small how would
you have done it he's in a garage with
wasn thec selling their calculator and
their Volkswagen to build a circuit
board how many Nerds were out there
doing that a billion you know they just
happened to be the two that made it
they're so small and yet when you
remember back when uh who was running it
was uh Obama and Romney and they were
fighting over whether or not GM could go
bankrupt here's this massive boohemoth
of a balance sheet for everyone to see
and it's clearly the bankruptcy is a is
a possibility if not a probability for
you know how easy that is to see mhm and
so going short lets us take something
it's off it's often easier to see big
problems than small startups you know in
reverse the other reason I like short is
for the Real Estate Investors a lot of
them really don't understand this it's
not about real estate it's about the
dollar mhm if you if you look at gold I
don't know if Gold's going up or down
you know longterm I don't know if
Apple's going up or down I have to watch
that you know month to month but if you
ask me where the US dollar is going to
go in 30 years it's a no-brainer in my
opinion well if you can borrow that when
it's worth something trade it for some
real estate and then give it to the bank
slowly back to the bank over 30 years
you're giving them back dollars that are
worthless MH right I probably said that
too fast yeah worth less worth less
right you're giv or worthless well you
know and so into him with interest also
yeah that's a shorting of the dollar
that's the way a guy like Warren buff
would look at that that real estate is a
great way to short the US dollar and so
that's a foreign idea to most people how
in the world do we make money when
things drop well if you look on the
horizon of some of the storm clouds that
are out there having that ability if it
does happen to hop in there oh my gosh
it can be the greatest opportunity you
ever has so that is actually fascinating
the the perspective of shorting the
dollar
because like when you're trading dollars
for gold you're shorting the dollar
right anytime you know there's four
steps to short you borrow something
trade it for something else trade it
back and return it yeah that's it MH and
so if even if you look at a financial
statement and you track the money from
the from the bank into the liability
column for loan that's a borrow from the
bank loan into the asset column of the
house that's a that's a b that's a trade
then you trade it back in rent and then
you return it back in a payment all four
steps of shorting a dollar are there 1 2
3 four if you learn how to short it's
fascinating stuff so if you're shorting
the market um and like you're talking
about like GM like you're saying hey
these are big and they're obvious but
isn't everybody else shorting it also at
that time or just's people taking the
other side of that you'd be surprised
there's there's a statistic called the
short interest you can find out how many
shares are short when a bank takes your
money in his savings they can loan it
out M and a brokerage can loan out
shares as well so it's the same idea
idea well the bank can tell you how much
money they've loaned out the Brokers can
tell you how many short shares they've
loaned out M and uh you'll be surprised
most people don't know how to short it's
risky because if you go long and a stock
goes down there's a limit to what you
can lose if you go short well how high
can it go Infinity that's theoretical
but it's still there right and there's
you know dividend risk and other other
risks to learn about but very few people
know how to short if you look at a guy
like George
Soros uh when the JP Japan came came out
and said well we're going to inflate the
the Yen we're going to go crazy and
print money and and print Yen and Sor
says great I'll short it he made a
billion dollars in one year just
watching the Yen drop so there are
opportunities for real investors high
level investors short we should not talk
about this without underscoring the
risks that's there these are
sophisticated relative to the lay person
they're sophisticated and they should
not be attempted without you know proper
knowledge so why didn't everybody else
short the end when they said we're going
to start inflating our currency I mean
wouldn't it be obvious that's what
everybody should do you know it's
interesting how many people really did
MH um when you look at the Forex Market
that's a that's a market has four
trillion going through today and for a
buyer there's a seller right all of
those pairings have someone on the other
side of it so you'd be surprised how
many people are short M and do bet
against things and it and it also gets
complex here though because let's say we
feel the dollars you know maybe in
trouble but uh it might be the the uh oh
how can I say this without having an
edit it's probably the least ugly girl
in the beauty contest is that is that
Politically Incorrect am I get hate mail
on that I I normally say uh it's uh it's
it's the talls pygm yeah there you go
exactly but when you look at um the
dollar you know it's going to hold some
strength for a little while because
where you know where else you you want
to put your money in the Euro you know
you want to uh put it in the Yen
probably not uh considering the monetary
policy so how much of your own uh income
would you say on average in a typical
year for you comes from shorting versus
other vehicles very little very little
okay yeah I it's it's
opportunistic uh you'll see something
like a GameStop or see something like a
a a short on the Euro or something like
that you'll hop in but very very little
okay um that's play money that's fun
money however um we've been in a bull
market haven't we and it wouldn't make
sense for me to be short on a lot of
stuff would it now if you ask me that in
five
years uh if we've had something drop
well I might have a different answer at
that point you know one of the things
that I
lamented um 10 years ago you know is
that I was not more aggressive in my
shorts um because we' never seen
anything like that before and hopefully
I'm 10 years old and 10 years wiser you
know 11 or however long it is now and so
ask me that in 10 years and we'll see
what it is but right now it wouldn't
make sense now I will say this if you
ask me what my income is in terms of
selling options when you're selling
those short and that's significant um
that that is an important part yeah of
what we do every single week so shorting
I think many people have heard the term
they kind of basic understanding of it
how do you how can you really illustrate
what short what's really going on when
somebody's shorting a stock it's a great
question because short positions are
backwards in your mind right it's uh how
in the world do I money when something's
going down and it's a lot of fun as I've
traveled around the world we've done
this in many languages and I found it
really helps if we want to do a little
lesson right here let Let's Do It um to
borrow something that's going down so
the first thing we got to get an idea on
Direction okay so let's get out of the
stock market out of the real estate
market let's just choose an object that
we think would
depreciate um one of the ones I'll use
often is a is a cell phone you have one
okay so here it is so brand brand new so
that's the iPhone 11 right brand new as
of this recording yep and if you sell
that on eBay what do you think you go
for today just so maybe well it's a 512
Pro so it was yesterday yesterday okay
it was $1,400 1400 bucks okay so let's
do this so let's go uh 700700 and that's
$1,400 so that'll work out great now if
you look at po last time we and I spoke
we said policy can tell us the future
right so what's Apple's policy on phones
how often they come out with a new one
every two years every two years so what
do you think the chances are that
they're going to come out with a iPhone
11 plus 11s 12 whatever it is what do
you think chances are 100% 100% y so
when that happens I'll draw a graph here
that your 11 we'll just put i1 here MH
will go from uh
$1,400 down to what the very day the new
one comes out uh I'm going to say $400
okay so let's go half okay let's go s
let's go 700 because that way the math
is easier for me okay so now we have a a
vision of something that's going to go
from 1,400 to 7 mhm now whether it'll
hit 7 or not what percent confidence do
you have that it will go down 100% so
that puts us in a nice situation what's
interesting is if you look at a
financial statement it's a there's a
fascinating component to it you have
assets and
liabilities if something in your asset
column goes up what will happen to your
net worth it increases it increases but
if something in your liability column
goes down what was your net worth do my
net worth increases so that tell tells
me there's two ways mhm to get rich yeah
I can buy things that are going up in
value or I can borrow things that are
going down in value mhm that's a huge
Epiphany for a lot of people they've
never thought say borrow them when you
say you're borrowing them at a certain
price or you're borrowing them waiting
them to go down well let's give it a
shot let's let's just see if it works
it's kind of a mindblower isn't it two
ways to get rich and it's kind of nice
because in order to buy an asset what do
you have to have an asset or have money
but in order to borrow money well you
just say can I borrow something so let
me let me give this a shot um can I
borrow your phone for a minute yeah okay
so I borrow your phone so here we go I
borrow this phone and now that I've
borrowed it uh I can do anything I want
with it now you still own it but I
possess it and think about this when you
borrow from a money from a bank what do
you do with the money whatever I want
yeah you do whatever you want is it your
money yeah uh no money bank money money
but you can do whatever you want with it
right what's the same thing here I can
do whatever I want with this phone so
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to sell it on eBay over here mhm and I'm
going to get 1,400 bucks for it right
there okay so I just went from zero to
1,400 right so now I wait and I wait I
wait and the iPhone you know 12 13 comes
out and down it goes MH so now it's down
at our $700 price so what should I do
well I'll buy it back and now I have
$700 in a phone mhm and my final thing
is is to return to you your phone now I
don't owe you anything and I'm left with
700 bucks uhhuh because I borrowed
something that went down in value now
that's a wonderful example that people
can practice and play with and why would
I lend this to you in the first place
because I asked you
to no what what let's say my interest on
it is 2% that's fine I'm making plenty
okay right it so I'm basically lending
it to you to get interest back on the
asset yeah mhm and that's exactly what
they do with the dollar isn't it mhm and
that's why real estate is about shorting
the dollar if it falls faster than that
interest rate and it's important you
mention that because why do you think
they amateu eyes M if they didn't they'd
get killed they have to get all that up
front right because if they waited 30
years they'd be getting dollars back
that aren't really that valuable are
they right learning how to borrow
something is going down and value and do
it with intelligence opens up a whole
new world for people a whole new view of
your financial statement buy things that
are going up in value borrow things that
are going down in value actually easier
to borrow things than to buy things
actually fascinating yeah well I guess
after all these years in summary here
because you've been doing this for a
while now long time long time some
decades and uh not only you're doing it
yourself but you you seem to have a lot
of passion about teaching it yeah um
does it stay interesting to you or are
you bored I'm absolutely fascinated ated
because I learn more every year you know
when people uh say Andy I'd like to be
one of your students I say well great
we're students together um the moment I
think a person takes the position that
they know something they stop learning
it's a it's a dangerous context to have
uh so I consider myself you all my
mentors were fellow students learning
every single year uh if I got in an
investing contest with Warren Buffett
I'd probably lose he's a lot smarter
than I am but uh all of us have equal
with different talents so the thing that
keeps me teaching is a person wants to
feel like you know some people have jobs
some people have careers some people
have callings and a calling is when
you're doing something that you're good
at that is you feel is for the greater
good uh that never gets boring for me
and if I uh if I'm limited in my talents
which are really I can change a light
bulb uh put a star on a Christmas tree
but I can also teach people how to short
and trade options um that third one that
ability to simplify has uh has been a
joy for me to help people with to take
things that are really complex on CNBC
boil it down to an example with a cell
phone that's awesome yeah a lot of fun
well Andy as always thanks so much for
coming here and sharing all the wisdom
and excitement about all this stuff it's
been really fun I I have been so
impressed with uh money revealed uh as I
watch those interviews and the the
people you've brought together it's a
project That's Unique uh in its kind and
I gained a lot of value as a student uh
watching all of those great mentors of
mine so thank you for having me and uh
thank you for the good you're doing
thanks so much
awesome we are over the moon excited
about the feedback we're getting from
the wealth breakthrough series and I
want to give a very sincere and special
thank you for those who bought the
series it supports us supports our work
allows us to get this out to the world
for free so people everywhere can have
their wealth breakthrough but for those
who bought the series it's especially
heartening to us to be able to know that
you're supporting this work so we can do
what we do every single
[Music]
day Andy Tanner just showed you
portfolio construction tactics that can
pay you safe dividends for life now
let's look at the other side how another
master of wealth who hasn't touched a
stock in years uses a unique niche of
the market to bag big gain after big
gain I'm talking about an often
misunderstood way you can turn 10% stock
moves into gains of 100% 200% or more
Alan nman is one of the most successful
option experts in America today and he's
got a heck of a story to prove to you
why right now is the greatest time in
history to trade the markets here's
Alan Alan thanks for taking the time to
have this conversation so uh tell us
about your background how did you get to
be doing what you're doing well I
started the exchange uh way back when
I've been doing this for almost 30 years
now uh working on the trading floor
worked with guys that uh had ivy league
degrees guys that didn't even finish
high school so you had to learn by doing
back then uh down on the trading floor
it was it was quite the uh quite the boy
club which trading floor were you
working on I was in Chicago at the uh at
the Chicago Board of Trade so I was down
on the grain floor and uh you started as
a runner which is not very glamorous
after getting out of college and you're
essentially picking up uh trade tickets
off the floor and bringing them back to
the desk so it's picking garbage but you
have to be able to pick the right
garbage so the team that in the desk
that you're on uh and bring those order
orders back but that really gives you
the background and the understanding of
the whole cycle of the trade from the
customer to the desk to the actual pit
to back to the CER customer so you get a
feel for how the markets really work uh
as opposed to now I think people don't
appreciate by just clicking on a screen
you know when they buy or sell something
really what's behind it and really the
supply and demand Dynamics can you walk
us through that then the the actual
cycle oh yeah so it's a very simple
process but it's it's you know happened
for 150 years there's still some open
outcry markets right now but very few uh
a customer would call in with the trade
they want to buy some corn contracts or
whatever it may be and that was in the
Futures Market obviously so they would
call the broker the broker would call a
desk on the trading floor the guy on the
trading floor would write down the
ticket buy so much corn uh for which
month and for which customer number hand
it to a runner the runner would take it
into the pit broker would fill the order
if it's if the Market's right there and
then they would drop the order ticket on
the floor another Runner would come by
pick up the pick up the ticket bring it
back to the desk the desk would call the
broker and the broker would call the
customer now that would all happen
within couple of minutes so it was very
efficient and and we're talking about
hundreds of millions of transactions
that happen that way very efficient very
fluid and obviously Everything Has
Changed with the electronic markets but
what that has done is given so many more
opportunities for everybody whereas like
it was a old boys club now with
electronic markets anybody can trade any
Market any direction any time so there's
always opportunity so those scenes where
you see like on you know the old scenes
from Trading floors and pits like your
people are screaming yelling it looks
like mass chaos uh that that's the
environment you were in but everybody
it's actually very organized uh it
doesn't look like it but every movement
every sound every hand gesture means
something and it's very efficient and
that's how it was done for 150 years and
uh it's amazing how much money was
transacted on a daily basis but that's
that's just the way it was now some of
those things are gone and working on the
trading floor I think I got to
appreciate the some of the money flows
and and the way uh the markets would
react and noise and quietness and fear
and you get some some clue clues that
you don't get when you're just staring
at a onedimensional screen yeah cuz
there's all these Dynamics going on that
you're just basically uh oblivious to I
guess right so you you started as a
runner what ended up happening from
there well that everybody starts at the
bottom and uh made $2.35 an hour was
real Rich uh and then eventually you
move up to be a phone Clerk and then you
end up being an assistant Trader and
then if you can get someone to back you
or if you can get some money you can
trade for yourself so that's the path
and uh you know everybody wants to go
down that route um and give it a try I
mean it's it's capitalism and its finest
if you can make the markets work for you
as a Trader you know there's nothing
there's nothing better in America it's
simply Supply demand it's simply you in
the markets you know you you you kill it
you eat it so you know that's that's the
beauty it's like I said it's it's pure
capitalism um but the problem is you
know N9 and a half out of 10 guys blow
up is they lose all their money uh is is
how it works so it's it's a it's quite
an environment but for most people it's
worth taking a swing at because if you
can make it work it's it's the best its
best vocation I guess you know you you
you don't have employees necessarily I
mean you might have assistant but you
don't have a store you don't have to you
don't have certain hours you don't have
inventory you don't have all these other
variables to deal with it's it's it's
pure pure capitalism back when you
started it was getting your foot in the
door it sounds like you said it's like
kind of a very closed Club you got to
get in so you know so the big I guess
breakthrough is trying to get through
that door and starting as a runner and
working your way up nowadays pretty much
anybody can enter the market right now
there are no barriers to trading there
are no barriers and you know with
commissions essentially free that's
actually a bad thing in my opinion
because people aren't as disciplined and
they don't plan their trades as well uh
as they need to because you know they
can be emotional and get in and out I
think commission actually uh performs a
function by making you think through a
trade but you get back to the barriers
to entry uh yeah it was it was you know
kind of Who You Knew um my uh my hiring
is very unique in the fact that I was in
the viewing Gallery one day and somebody
on the trading floor saw me and sent his
assistant up and asked me if I wanted a
job and I'm like sure and started and
worked from there um years later I found
out it was because I was tall not
because I'm smart so you know I'd like
to I like to think otherwise but uh
being tall was an advantage you know
because I'm six2 so people can see you
in the pit and that's visibility is is a
key wow that's interesting yeah you're
not tall on on the screen when you're
trading online right exactly it doesn't
matter how tall you are that's right if
you're sitting on your wallet you can be
tall so uh there's different kinds of
trading I guess I mean you if we're
looking at day trading or maybe you know
kind of maybe longer term you know time
Horizons what have you can you describe
the different forms of trading as you
see it now well first I like to use the
words trading and investing
interchangeably uh people have a
negative connotation with the word
trading trading is not negative trading
is someone that has a plan they know
where they want to get in they know
where they want to get out if it goes
for them and if it goes against them so
they're in it for a long series of high
probability positions an investor
doesn't really have a plan investor buys
or sell something and they say they'll
get out when it goes up or down okay
they you know they they don't really
have a plan so a Trader is actually a
more sophisticated investor so I think
being a Trader obviously is is a
positive if you can look at look at in
those terms um so going down that path I
think it doesn't matter what you trade
or how you trade you have to have a
discipline you have to have a plan and
the key is about you know putting uh
risk reward on your side um and my big
breakthrough I thought years ago was
when I ventured in the options space so
options is really or options are really
just a better way to trade a smart
Trader can take advantage so many
variables when it comes to options you
know when you're buying or selling a
stock it's binary either goes up or down
right you've got a 50-50 chance with
options there are so many pieces of the
option I make it very simple I'm not
trying to be the smart option options
guy um I'm just using options as a
vehicles but I can control my
probability I can decide that I only
want to put on positions at a guy of a
70 75% chance of being successful I can
control time I can control volatility
there's so many different things uh that
are beneficial there's always a better
way to trade using options than just
strictly buying or selling the stock
with that being true why isn't everybody
doing options like what keeps people
into trading you that amazes me that
completely amazes I mean when you turn
on that light bulb for people they
completely get it and they're like I
can't believe I've been trading stocks
here in the past and there's always a
better way and and just a basic stock
substitution strategy where you're
buying it in the money call that's going
to behave like the stock you have less
money tie up you got limited risk you've
got some staying power to ride through
the ups and downs and and most
importantly you've got a significantly
greater payout because of the leverage
with your option when you're right when
it moves in your favor so it's going to
act like the stock so if nothing Happ
happens you know it's it's it's not
detrimental to you mhm but if there's a
small modest move in the underlying
stock a 5% move that option could gain
50% if there's a 10% move in the stock
that option would gain 100% so it's it's
all about math and I think once people
look at it and overcome their anxieties
and fears about options you know I think
the light bulbs on and they'll never go
back to stocks if I open up a brokerage
account let's say with the ER Trader at
Merit trade what have you and uh I start
to just trade equities uh not options
who am I competing against you're
competing against everybody I know
people a lot of people get uh overly I
guess concerned about the high frequency
Traders they really have a limited
impact on the market they're trying to
make parts of a penny so they're
providing a little liquidity I'm not
worried about those guys and the way I
trade I'm not a short-term Trader I used
to be when I was younger that's not as
much fun as you think it is it's not as
glamorous as you think it is being
chained your computer and any burp or
blip in the market is a deal that you
have to handle I use options to trade
longer term I'm looking usually 3 to 6
months out if not longer than that so I
can ride through the ups and downs I can
look at markets more on a weekly basis I
call them lifestyle options they fit my
lifestyle so I don't have to sit there
in front of the computer all day but I'm
still taking advantage of great
opportunities in the market and and I
can't say it enough this is the best
time in history let me say that again
the best time in history to trade the
markets there's always opportunity when
I was a young kid you know whatever pit
you were in if there wasn't something
happening that day you could force a
trade end up losing money or you know
you you could keep your hands down or
you could go home so you know any day
there's always opportunity so things are
so much different than they used to be
I'm always optimistic that there's
opportunity it's just my job to sort it
out and take advantage of it if I decide
to become an options Trader as you're
suggesting or recommending when when
okay when I decide to become okay very
good uh who am I competing with now is
it a different group of people and is it
a different dynamic in that in that
competitive pool well somewhat it
depends on what type of trading you're
doing but some of the best Minds in the
markets use options because they're so
much better vehicle so if you're a smart
guy if you're Goldman Sachs or Morgan
Stanley and you have a strong opinion of
what you think is going to happen you're
going to use the options Market it's
going to give you the the best payoff
and it's going to give you uh limited
risk you're going to get better use of
your Capital so that's where they're
going to load up if they've got a very
strong opinion and something a Stock's
going to do um so you you're in the same
marketplace with those guys but then
there are also uh novice options Traders
and the reason that options get a bad
name so to speak for some people is
because they've learned the hard way
they buy too little time and they their
their strike prices are too far out of
the money meaning that they're really
just long shot options so even if the
market moves their way they've got those
variables working against them so once
you understand those components and
Factor them out of the equation like I
do buying enough time and in the money
options and so forth try and make it
very easy using options is the vehicle
uh once you eliminate that then then
it's Off to the Races so it's it's
really just about the math but the
beauty of the options Market it's very
transparent that every trade that every
person makes is seen on the screen so if
somebody's loading up uh in in in some
company uh that's going to be visible
and you're going to be able to see that
it's it's very transparent and uh it's
got very tight liquidity now as opposed
to years ago now we have pennies spreads
meaning the difference between where you
want to buy and where you want to sell
uh whereas in the past it used to be you
know 20 or 30 cents so that's really
made execution of your trading plan uh
very very uh smooth so I've got a
college senior graduating with a
economics and finance degree figuring
out what he wants to do and uh so now I
I I should say to him like if this was
your son would you be giving him or
anybody that's watching right now it's
the reason I'm asking the question
advice saying you know I think if you
want to move into the area you know of
of uh stocks or options what have you
that options is really the thing to
master the thing to learn and that's
it's a sustainable way uh to develop
wealth over time is is that the way you
see it oh absolutely there's really no
reason to trade an individual stock you
may want to hold it to get dividends but
that's really that's really the only
example you're going to be much better
off with an options uh play or an option
strategy uh based on whether you think
the Market's going up down sideways
where you think the Market's going to go
where it's not going to go what's going
to happen as far as the time component
increase or decrease in volatility
there's so many variables you can take
advantage of so it's it's definitely the
route to go now to get back to the
economics degree when I went to college
there were no classes on trading you
just had to learn by doing it and you
know like I said I'm going on my 30th
year of this so I've seen it all and
I've done it all but the the one thing I
want to stress is be optimistic be
optimistic of the opportunity there's
always money to be made markets aren't
good or bad they up they go down but the
more the markets move I always say
volatility is opportunity because more
the markets move it's our job to take
that piece out of it so let's maybe get
granular now walk me through an options
trade what is actually happening how do
you go in it how do you come out of it
what are the upsides what are the risks
well if you're simply buying options
which is what I recommend it's limited
risk the maximum exposure you have is
what you pay in in premium explain what
an option is literally so an option
controls 100 shares of a stock so if you
want to trade Coca-Cola uh you're
controlling 100 shares of of that
underlying stock uh and you're paying a
premium for that you're paying a certain
amount um and then you to unwind it you
sell that option so depending on your
strategy depending on your outlook where
you think the Market's going to go and
and over what period of time that will
help you determine which strike which
month and all these other uh uh
variables but I try and make it super
super simple if I think the Market's
going up I'm buying a call if I think
the Market's going down I buy a p so
imagine that I don't know what a call or
a put is so you know explain what those
things are so let's say that um let's do
like a use case here okay so here I am
I've opened up my account now you've got
me convinced I should be doing options
I'm I'm a Fool If I'm going to just you
know buy stock and right well tell me
the stock tell me a stock that you like
so let's say uh Amazon let's say I like
Amazon I think it's going to move up up
not down and uh so I want to buy options
on it so what what's my process well
Amazon's going to be difficult because
it's such an expensive stock so the
options are going to be more expensive
give me a stock I should be looking at
so let's let's look at something like
let's say Intel okay Intel trading
around 60 or so so you could buy a 55
call uh for let's say June I don't know
what a 55 call is okay 55 gives you the
right to belong from 55 if the Market's
trading at 57 that's at a discount to
where it's actually trading at at at now
so you have the right to belong from
that price you're not going to exercise
that you're buying the option and then
you're looking to sell the option if the
market moves up it's going to increase
in value obviously so it's very
straightforward uh but the idea here is
because you're controlling that 100
shares I think that's the point I want
to get across and not get too much into
the the the logistics of this is you're
controlling 100 shares of the stock
something's trading at what we say 57 so
100 times 57 is
$5,700 is is the value of of that option
now if you want to buy the stock it's
$5,700 the option might only cost $400
or $500 so you're for one tenth of your
in investment you're getting the same
control so some people look at it they
don't understand the positivity of the
leverage because you have that $400 or
$500 you're paying for that option
that's your maximum risk no matter what
happen is that the maximum risk that's
your maximum risk no matter where Intel
goes if intel goes to you know 20 you
know that the the worst thing that can
happen is your option expires worthless
you're out that $400 or $500 you can put
a stop loss in it just like you can on a
stock but I think as a vehicle it's
important for people to understand the
capital outlay is usually you know a
tenth of what it would take to buy or
sell the shares of stock and that's
that's huge because you're getting much
better use for your money and with the
June option you're you know in this
example we're looking at about five
months out or whatever um you know
that's that's some time for development
I'm not planning to be in it that long
necessarily uh but I have that time so I
don't have to worry about that that
component being an issue that's one
thing at the exchange the guys on the
trading floor at the uh any any uh
options exchange the guys on the floor
made their money over the past years by
selling these out-of- the money what we
call lottery tickets to novice Traders
and novice Trader comes in and says
listen I think that Nel is going to go
up I want the Intel $70 call because
it's trading at $25 the reason it's
cheap is because the mathematic
probability of that being in the money
at expiration is almost zero but if
those guys sell those options every
single month sell those front month what
we call lottery tickets they're
collecting that money and unless there's
a huge move in that that stock they keep
that money from the novice Traders so
they do that monthin month out that's
why those guys have the best houses the
best cars the best lives uh by taking
advantage of that time Decay and the
people that don't understand the basics
of options so the there definitely are
predators out there taking market makers
oh oh is that what they're called market
makers there are people that are making
a market and if you you know you can buy
and sell anything you want you know
they're not telling you what to buy but
they just if those people don't
understand the odds right but the
predators in a sense of they're saying
hey you're ignorant I'm going to sell
you something that has a very low
probability of succeeding well I mean
wouldn't anybody want to do that I mean
that's the perfect that's a perfect
business and that's and that's why I
guess ignorance is is a problem so I
guess information and current
information and learning I mean these
are important aspects you don't just
show up one day and say hey I think I'll
do this you need some guidance would you
agree with that right yeah and and like
I said I try and make it as simple as
possible um and my stock substitution
strategy is what I do 90 95% of the time
where I'm just buying a call or or a put
that's in the money that's going to act
like the stock so I'm using all the
positives of of options but I'm getting
the benefits of the underlying stock
move if I can anticipate Direction which
I have a pretty good handle on and then
you're going to get a much better payoff
with an option than you would the stock
can you do options also on indices or or
is it just stocks yeah you can do
options on almost anything options on
Futures options on uh stocks options on
indes so options are just a tool and for
a lot of people they they seem
intimidating but they shouldn't be once
you get into that first trade and
understand the basics like I said that
light goes on you get it and you're like
dang I shouldn't have been I shouldn't
have been in stocks all these years this
is a such a much better way to trade do
you trade any stocks uh anymore or
when's the last time you have no I can't
even think of like I said unless you're
trying to get in you're just putting a
stock in a brokerage account to get the
dividend or something I don't I don't
see why you would even want to do that
there's a there's a much better way to
do it now some stocks when they first
come available aren't optionable right
away um you know if you're talking about
something that just IPOs and stuff like
that takes a couple weeks for the
exchange to get the options up and
running but the answer for me the answer
for me is no I don't I don't see any
reason to trade a stock do you have a uh
preferred place where you trade uh as
far as uh you know which floor you might
trade on no I I don't try and
predetermine wherever the the
opportunity is and now with you know
technology uh your orders just
automatically go to where you can get
the best price I think there's what 16
maybe options exchanges so years ago
before the markets got efficient is a
polite way to put it uh the the
brokerages would route orders to where
they wanted so you weren't always
getting the best price and and for a
while we could take advantage of that um
because you could buy in one exchange
and sell in the other exchange but now
the markets are so liquid and that's
such an important attribute right now
that there's so many buyers there's so
many sellers that the spreads are so
tight with no commissions and tight
spreads you can execute your trading
plan so that's why it's important to be
a Trader and have that plan you know
where you want to get in like I said if
you put it buy a $500 option and you put
in a stop loss at $250 because you don't
want to you know risk the whole thing
you know it's a lot better to get out
you can always get back inh than uh you
know trading on Hope because hope is not
a trading strategy hoping that it comes
back right you say there's zero
commission I mean is that is that actual
I mean there's it's it's a low a lot of
a lot of the brokerage firms have zeroed
out their commissions for stocks but for
options I think it's 65 cents so
essentially it's zero and like I said
before if you're worrying about
commissions that's you're focus in the
wrong place uh the reality is you know
commissions make you think about your
trading strategies this is not this is
not gambling this is probability this is
a long string of high probability
positions so over the long run you're
going to come out come out ahead it's
not about you know today it's about next
week next month next next year is doing
this on a consistent basis and using the
right option strategy I think allows
people to do that uh because it's it's
more
lifestyle friendly uh instead of
worrying about you know the markets ups
and downs and we've had amazing ups and
downs but uh it's I again come back to
the optimism we've overcome every each
and every crisis over the last decade
that that should be heads spinning if
you reviewed it I mean brexit
impeachment trade Wars you know viruses
deaths just in the last months okay any
one of those in the past would have been
you know a market stopper but um I I
think people have to be conditioned to
the the the continued opportunity in the
marketplace and uh I know there guys
that you interviewed that say the end is
near but you know where's that gotten
them in the last 10 years no kidding I
mean you can keep predicting it but it's
as you said I mean it's almost like the
market starting to say you know you guys
just go and have your little Hissy Fits
over here we know what's really going on
as far as wealth in this world right and
it it comes down to again to supply and
demand there there's only so much um so
many public companies and and and it's
about money flow money's chasing yield
and and the yield has been in the stock
market for for the past decade or more
and with interest rates continuing to go
lower there's not really any choice
until there's a choice until short-term
interest rates are at four or five perc
and people have a choice
uh between putting their money in
treasuries or putting it in stocks
people are going to continue to put it
in the stock market yeah there will be
ups and downs and bumps but I think the
overall trajectory you know people are
conditioned to take in a certain amount
of their paycheck putting their 401K
certain certain amount into the markets
each and every month and I don't I don't
know what's going to change that maybe
someday that'll that'll happen and we'll
know that we'll be able to take
advantage of it I don't care I mean I do
care if the markets continue to go up I
want them to go up but I don't care if
markets go up or down you know I just I
just want to make money and there's
always going to be there's always going
to be money to be made you know it's
interesting uh I think you just made a
point that kind of struck me is that uh
there's a limited amount of you know
stock or companies that are out there
right and it seems like there's more and
more Capital coming to invest somewhere
and uh you know when that's happening
you know what can it do but drive the
market well there you go see the
economics degree is coming through now
it's supply and demand so you can see
that if there's money you know chasing a
limited amount finite amount of assets
actually 's been less and less stocks on
the exchanges over the last last years
as as fewer and fewer companies you know
come come public and there's been
mergers and Acquisitions and so forth
you know so there's you know the money
flow the money has to go somewhere uh
and the question is you know two big
choices stocks or bonds and you know I
don't think that uh that the smart money
is going to go into the bond market to
get you know 1 and a half% yield no
kidding so when you look into to the
Future and I I imagine you do that um
and you see uh what you think is going
on so obviously you're very bullish you
think that hey you this is this this
trend is great it's going to continue
the sky is not falling uh it seems to be
your perspective would that be accurate
yeah but I've been bullish for I would
say 10 almost 10 years so and I'm very
uh a very technical Trader and for me
it's important to see how the markets
act and then more importantly than that
is how they react and each and every
time we've had a sell off a pullback the
markets have responded and made new all
time highs and actually if you look at
it every time there's been a drop if we
go back to December of
2018 when we had the the trade War
concerns and the stock market sold off
10% you take the distance that drop on
those old highs and that's achieved
that's a full V recovery it's achiev new
all-time highs each and every time in
Market history until it doesn't but you
just use that very simple technique and
we still have more upside from that last
selloff in the S&P so let's see once we
achieve that where we are uh I'm not
saying it's going to be a straight up
move I'm not just blindly bullish I just
like the market action I like the
fundamentals and if we get into what the
stock market really is the stock market
is is a valuation on future revenues
okay who's making money corporations are
are making a lot a lot of money so you
know until that changes uh the stock
market's still the place to be so let's
say okay now I'm watching this you got
be convinced uh you know options I all
these years I've been in stocks and
options sounds like the right thing to
do if I want to you know start trading
um but maybe there's some people who
shouldn't be doing this also so can you
give the profile of the maybe the person
who should maybe enter options trading
and the person who should maybe steer
away from it well depends on how soon
you need your money uh if you're close
to retirement or something like that as
not I'm not a financial adviser from
that standpoint you know that's that's a
different game now if you're trading the
markets I don't think it matters who you
are if you're actually trading the
market so this is a better way to trade
like I said you you've got higher
probabil ility you've got lower risk
you've got lower capital outlay and
you're able to have some staying power
when you can buy some time to ride the
ups and downs in the market so I
wouldn't say to eliminate anybody when
it comes to options if you're a Trader
and you have that mentality uh that I I
I cannot think of any reason not to um
but it's it doesn't matter what the
vehicle is it doesn't matter what you
trade if you don't have discipline and
you don't have follow your trading plan
you're not going to be successful I
don't care if it's trading penny stocks
or mutual funds or you know buying gold
coins if you don't have have a plan and
you're getting uh very emotional about
what's going on that's where people get
themselves in trouble and I think that's
one advantage I have over a lot of other
people is that um I understand the
psychology of the markets and I have a
good feel for how people's behavior is
impacting what the markets are doing and
um the fact that people more and more
people are as optimistic as I am that
has raised a little bit of a red flag
for me because I kind of have more of an
opposite Viewpoint a lot of times and uh
and I understand how the markets work
and and and how people have how people
behave and how how I can take advantage
of that because they get uh they're
they're often times selling when they
should be buying and buying when they be
should be selling in the last few months
I I've been unloading a lot of positions
and selling too soon is what I always
tell people is I'm accused of and I do
it all the time I sell way too soon
way too soon but so what still made
money that's why that's why we do this
you can always get back in there's more
opportunities there's something else but
sell too soon is a mantra that I often
get accused of what's the learning curve
so let's say Okay um at least I've got
some experience you know trading stocks
uh but now you got me convinced again
options I really should be looking at
what's my learning curve to get into
this type of a oh the stock substitution
strategy just a couple of weeks you'll
be up and running and get it it's it's
very straightforward so instead of
buying or selling a stock you're just
buying a call or buying a put it's
straightforward it's simple um and buy
it at least three months time and it's
just math and you know uh I'm not trying
to be the number cruncher guy because
the markets are now so e efficient that
you know if something theoretically was
undervalued or overvalued that's how
guys used to make their money in the
options Market that doesn't happen
anymore the markets are completely
efficient and everything's fairly priced
and so that's not my game my game is
just trying to be ridiculously simple
and I've got options friends that are
like number cruncher option Geeks and
they don't consider me an options Trader
they just consider me a Trader but I use
options as my vehicle because it has so
many advantages that's an interesting
distinction actually you know saying hey
you know there's I think they're doing
it in kind of a Sly slight way that
they're saying that I'm not as smart as
they are but you know I I let the
success make up for that how smart you
are is reflected in the numbers that's
what I say exactly look at the results
it's all about results so they're just
trying to make themselves feel better
right but they they had the right number
on a piece of paper but that number on a
piece of paper doesn't necessarily make
you money so it's all about making money
I don't care how I get there uh using
the markets legitimately so looking into
how somebody needs um I guess
information flow I mean I know that you
you write on this and that you uh you
know you kind of talk about options
trading publicly and you have a
following around this um so uh is
ongoing information important because
you said you're a technical Trader so
you're looking you at technical things
but is there general you know Market
information that that informs me if I'm
option sharing the first thing I'll tell
you is turn off your TV turn off your TV
do not watch it I'm on TV no CNBC I'm on
TV at least twice a day all right so
Bloomberg Fox News uh CNBC I'm on at
least twice a day but don't listen to
anything that people say because there
are very few guys on TV or women anybody
that's going to go on TV and here to
tell you anything that's can help you
make money a lot of it is just
mental um Manu
they're just talking to hear themselves
talk they're not going to give you
anything specific to help you make money
they're not going to say where to buy
where to sell what to risk they're not
you know and a lot of times they're
fighting the last battle they're talking
about something that's already happened
and and they're may be fearful of
something up up ahead so turn that off
because all that does is affects your
your psychological approach to markets
SO trading is is is not exciting trading
is not fun is even though we might
making money is fun but trading is not
fun it should be very mechanical process
you identify the opportunities you
execute with your trading plan you
manage your trade and then you maximize
the market move that's it it's it's it's
it's making sausage all I'm doing is I'm
in a different Market I'm just I'm just
you know I got a little machine and I'm
just cranking it out the process I'm not
um I'm not trying to be the smart guy
it's not about my opinion it's really
just about facts and and and numbers and
and like I said turn the TV off because
a lot of times that just causes
confusion and if you notice they're in
the business they're in the business of
getting you emotional all right right
they want you to stay watching their
Channel they want you to be glued to
your seat they want you not to be able
to turn off because the next number is
going to be the next greatest thing
that's ever going to you know impact
your portfolio and uh they're they're
always thinking short short term I'm
thinking you know 6 months nine months a
year out is is where my head is I'm
always trying to do this like chess with
two moves away uh whereas they've got
you focused on the near term so they can
sell ads understand the business that
they're in they're selling advertising
they're infotain they're not there to
help you make money they're there to
sell ads so tell me how you identify
opportunities what are you looking for
well I I'm uh I just look at a lot of
charts and I pay attention to a lot of
markets and I've got a pretty good
handle uh I started in the Commodities
markets like I said long ago and it
really all comes back to Commodities so
if you can get a good handle on what's
happening with interest rates what's
happening with uh with gold with oil
with some of these physical Commodities
they're kind of the building blocks for
everything so as they move move that's
going to impact Stock A Bank stock
you're not going to trade a bank stock
unless you have a handle what's going on
with interest rates right so you know
everything's all tied together so I
think I've got a good handle on how how
the supply and demand of the underlying
Commodities has an impact on the stocks
and and how stocks react but I think
more importantly I've got a great handle
on Market psychology I've been through
this a lot all right I get a certain
sense when there's not enough fear or
when there's too much fear in the
marketplace and like I said that's
opportunity and for me when I feel that
way I'm not saying that I'm Nostradamus
I'm saying that when I feel that way
that I can put down an options position
that has a great risk reward so when
sometime sometimes things look the worst
you know that may be the time best time
to be the buyer of that because at that
point what's happened psychologically is
you've read and seen so much negative
news so much negative news about this
stock and this company and everybody's
fully aware of that and that's driven
that stock or that company way down and
at some point it runs out of bad news so
it's so bad it has to be a buy and then
if you can buy a six Monon or a 9mon or
one-year option on it then you can be in
position for when that when that fear
alleviates and a lot of times you're
going to see a snap a little bit of a
rubber band snap back when people
realize it's not as bad as what people
thought it was so when you are making
more money and you're accumulating more
uh you know liquid liquidity or more
cash are you investing also outside of
that or do you just say you know what I
just as I have more cash as a basis I
just buy more options or do you actually
put U for your own personal wealth
accumulation do you put money to work
outside of trading options oh yeah I put
money to work outside definitely and one
one funny thing was I was on uh Fox
Business one day and I had this was a
couple years ago and this was in the
real estate market was having a tough
time and uh and I was on with a real
estate expert and they wanted our
opinions where to put our money now my
idea and and I acted on it was I bought
a beach house and his idea even though
he's a real estate guy was to go into
the stock market so it was about the
timing of the opportunities when they
there that was after the market had an
extended extended extended run obviously
there's always more upside but the risk
reward may not be as significant or
might not be to my liking so then no I
I'll I'll I'm open to uh to to any any
and all opport unities uh but I will say
for novice Traders or new options
Traders learn to trade one option let's
just say two options at a time okay
start with one option people think you
got to trade 10 options or 20 options or
30 options okay learn to trade one or
two options learn the process learn how
to get in learn how to get out learn to
make money learn to take a loss learn
that process and you can always become a
bigger and better Trader okay don't
start at 10 or 20 options because if you
have a couple losses then you're
psychologically going to you know be in
a tail spin and then it's harder to make
back your money when you're trading less
options so start small become a bigger
Trader and I always trade in pairs
because that way it gives me flexibility
like I said I sell too soon so I'll take
off half of my position if I can get to
50% and then I'll keep the other half in
if if it can get up to 100% now you're
looking at me like 50 and 100% that's
that's pretty significant well with
options you can get these big big moves
with a small move in the underlying
stock so like that Coca-Cola example or
the Intel example if the stock just
moves 5% that option can gain 50% so
it's all about the math I'm not uh I'm
not trying to say I pick the bottom and
sell the top but it's all about math and
you get these exponential gains just
because of the math of the right option
and you like so when you're winning you
like to just take chips off the table
rather than let them keep riding yeah
yeah yeah that's not something I'm good
at I'm not I I hate gambling to be
honest with you I mean people go to uh
casinos or go to Las Vegas for fun but I
I don't think it's fun at all I mean
it's it's not fun because you know the
odds are not on your side it's gambling
right right that's gambling if I I want
to be in a position where I can put odds
in my favor where I can control my risk
where I can you know have a significant
payoff when I'm right you know this is
this is not gambling this is probability
and and and I can't stress that enough
here's something I find puzzling there's
a lot of these people who pontificate
about the markets and stock on yeah okay
and you are you do that also but I'm
seeing a lot of these people who are on
TV uh you know uh saying these things to
the masses who have horrible track
records as far as calling stuff so how
how do they sustain I ideology people
will subscribe to a certain ideology the
markets don't care what your personal
beliefs are the markets don't care if
you're Republican or Democrat the
markets are the markets all right that's
what we're there to to take advantage of
and and make money from but there are
many many guys that I work with that go
on the air repeatedly and they are
completely wrong but people are have the
same ideology as they do and the same
beliefs so they'll stick with them
thinking eventually they're going to be
right so you have to think to yourself
do you want to be do you want to be
right from a political or ideological
standpoint or do you want to be right
making money for me it's making money
right I don't you know the market
doesn't care what my personal beliefs
are that's for sure so this theme of
this series is wealth breakthroughs so
is there a an inflection point or or
maybe a number of things that you can
point to for yourself personally that
were wealth breakthroughs for you I
think for me once I realized that it's
there are so many opportunities um that
I don't have to be as laser focused and
I can't worry about missing that that
one one event uh you have to think big
picture and nowadays each and every day
I can't say enough these are the best
times in history with these Market moves
I mean look what's happened with
technology stocks look what's you know
even if there is a sell-off there's ways
to make money you know and and and
usually very quickly uh on Market
declines so the money movement that we
see now is so much different than when I
was younger and I think that's that's
the Breakthrough is that there's always
opportunity I used to get very upset
when I lost money and I still don't like
to lose money um but my wife would ask
me if uh if if I left a a instrument in
a patient or anybody died today and I
had to I had to you know think to myself
that it's just money I can always make
more it's about having a discipline to
attack the opportunity each and every
day I think that's the big breakthrough
after your Decades of of success you
know you you 2.9 decades 2.9 decades
it's not it's not quite 30 Years yet so
but you've accumulated you know a
significant amount of wealth for
yourself it doesn't seem like you need
to do this anymore uh are you changing
your ways at all or uh are you you still
my lifestyle has changed in the fact
that that's why I ventured in options so
that I can do what I want to do so I can
live the life that I want to live and
not be not be chained to the markets or
or just imagine being in a in a trading
pit all day every day yelling and
sweating on somebody else you know that
I that that doesn't sound like fun to
meore so you know this is the key is the
freedom to do you know what you want
when you want um but you still don't
want to leave the markets alone it's
it's uh it's it's a great time it's a
great time right now that's terrific
Alan I really appreciate you taking the
time to share all this with us really
inform and entertaining love your energy
so thank you thanks a
[Music]
lot taxes just saying the word can send
chills down your spine Tom Wright's the
tax experts tax expert he's a
best-selling author in CPA and has one
core message to share with you lowering
the taxes you pay is the quickest way to
immediately boost the amount of money
you take home plus almost every American
makes these common tax mistakes that
could be costing you thousands but in
this interview he goes over simple
effective ways to quickly and legally
cut your taxes by 20% even 25% or more
keep more of what you make get a tax
strategy in place that works for your
family it's one of the easiest wealth
breakthroughs that you'll ever find
let's get
started Tom thank you for being here
thanks for having me yeah this is you uh
uh I've actually wanted to interview you
for about a year you were recommended to
us um a year ago we were asking tax
questions to Robert kosaki and finally
goes you just need to talk to my tax guy
and we he I think he mentioned your book
that that they published and so I
ordered the book literally sitting there
usually my partner does the interviews
and I'm sitting behind the camera and I
ordered the book on Amazon and I still
haven't read it my household manager as
soon as it came in she got it and she
started working on it and took this book
of yours and educated uh her CPA with it
and literally as recent as last week uh
she was still making changes on her
taxes actually went back I think like
five or six years and took some loss on
a business that she had that she didn't
know she could take and redid her taxes
based on your book so the fact that I
haven't been able to access your book
not like there's only one copy in the
world maybe I should just go ahead and
buy my second copy but do know that book
did come into a to Great use and is
turned into money so I'm excited to talk
to you about uh how people can stop
wasting money on paying taxes that are
unnecessary great that's my life that's
so tell me a little bit about you and
how you got to where you are so I uh I
was mentioning earlier I grew up in Salt
Lake City Utah uh of course grew up
Mormon so spent two years after high
school in Paris actually uh teaching
Mormonism to Catholics and learning all
about rejection which uh was great great
great great and um and then I went to
the University of Utah where I did my
undergraduate work in accounting and
went to the University of Texas for my
uh graduate work in accounting
and um then spent six years at erston
Young including three years in their
National Tax Department in fact the last
time we had a major tax reform 1986 I
was in Washington DC um actually
participating in the tax reform effort
so that was uh that was a great Learning
lesson and we also trained uh the
accountants around the country is what
we did at National Tax um from there I
went to uh Pinnacle West Capital which
was at the time a Fortune 500 company
and and I was an in-house Tax Advisor
there I spent 14 years as an Adjunct
professor at Arizona State University
and their masters of tax program and the
last 25 years uh built an international
accounting firm and sold it and built
another one and now I actually we run a
network of CPA firms around the country
and as you know I've been traveling the
world with Mr kosaki in fact just got
back from Japan uh with Mr kosaki and
group and we talk about
taxes and amazingly enough they're the
same in every country so it's easy to
talk about well this there seems to be a
wide gap
between U what like my average CPA knows
and what's really a available
to for deductions and I want to get into
some specific Tax Strategies but why
like choosing a CPA it's almost like
choosing a therapist you know there can
be a wide range of outcomes well it's
like choosing a doctor I mean you go
from a chiropractor to a heart surgeon
and you have to decide you know what
what do you want but really it's a
matter of perspective um my perspective
is quite different than the typical CPA
most people are afraid of taxes and my
perspective is that in in essence the
tax law is really a series of incentives
and that's all it is I mean if you look
at it there's only about 30 pages that
raise tax taxes and there's 6,000 Pages
how does somebody if they're searching
for a CPA how does somebody vet them
that to know that the perspective of
that CPA well you know what's
interesting is like I said um most
people are scared to death of taxes
including most CPAs and so really what I
would be looking for is what's their
perspective on taxes to me the the tax
law is really the way the government
creates incentives to get we to get us
to do what what the government wants to
have done so if the government wants us
to hire employees they give us
incentives for hiring employees um the
government found out years and years ago
back in the 60s that the cheapest way to
incentivize people to get something done
is through a tax break whether it's
buying a home whether it's sending your
kids to college um whether it's adopting
children or whether it's uh building
low-income housing for you know for
thousands and thousands of people so
that's what the government does is
they've used the tax law as a way to
engineer um the economy and energy and
society and frankly it works pretty well
because you get people putting money
where the government wants them to put
it so this philosophy that that comes
from you and and and I you know maybe
surely you didn't are the only person in
the world thinking this way but I was
first exposed to it from Robert kosaki
he's like look I'm doing what the
government wants me to do I'm playing
you know it's it's really almost the
opposite of a cat Mouse game maybe I can
hide it here maybe I can you know hide
it it's it's a a a really fresh
perspective how do we how do I do I shop
for a CPA do I educate a CPA how do I
get somebody on my team well you know
first thing I suggest is you buy my book
taxfree wealth right and actually put a
whole chapter in there that was the one
chapter that Robert insist I put in
there um was how to find a Tax Advisor
and the the key to a Tax Advisor I think
there's two keys one's their perspective
and I think that that's key because I
can't tell you how many times I've had
um people tell me they were told not to
take a legitimate tax deduction because
they were advised not to buy their
accountant or bu their Tax Advisor um I
actually heard people tell me that their
accountant told them that the way to pay
less taxes was to make less money I'm
going that has got to be the dumbest
advice in the history of the world right
seriously I mean the highest tax bracket
is 40% well 60 if you're in California
but it's it's not that high it's not
100% right so of course you don't want
to ever make less money but you do want
to pay less tax so it's a matter of
finding somebody with the perspective
but it's also a matter of finding
somebody who's interested in you because
um as I always like to say if you want
to change your tax you have to change
facts and because it's all fact and
circumstances driven so if I'm going to
change your taxes I need to know
everything about you I mean literally I
know more than your therapist because I
do know I know about your family I know
about your relationship with your
children I know about your relationship
with your wife because what you're going
to do with them all has an impact on
your taxes everything you do has an
impact on your taxes every dollar you
spend every dollar you earn everything
you do has an impact on your taxes so so
I'd better understand everything about
you so the the first thing I tell people
is you want to find a good tax adviser
find somebody who's asking questions
about you instead of you having to ask
them questions if you have to ask them
questions you're the wrong person you
know I I used to be uh when it came time
to do my taxes every year it felt like I
was going to the principal's office
where I would go in and he would
chastise me for all the things I hadn't
done the previous year and
I kept searching for some I'm like okay
can you start telling me this before the
year Jeff I need you to do this not as
we get close to April way you should
have done this um if you were to advise
people forward thinking of putting your
house in order for taxes what are some
things that people can do now to make
sure they're prepared
for to to have a better outcome well it
it's not a one-year situation it's a
lifetime situation so you know the most
people spend their time on taxes
deferring or postponing taxes they do
401ks and do IAS and they do pension
plans and PR sharing plans which is
mostly a complete waste of time because
if you're going to postpone your taxes
that presumes that you want to retire
poor because the only way it works is if
you're in a lower tax bracket when
you're retire than you are when you're
working and the only way you're in a
lower tax bracket when you retire is if
you're making less money so to me the
whole idea of postponing your your tax
liability is an idea of I am going to
retire with less money than I have now
and I've just never met anybody really
wanted to do that well the good news is
is that 90% of the tax law is permanent
tax reduction it's not temporary tax
reduction that's just the easy stuff
that I always say easy is a four-letter
word right because it's what accountants
go to when they don't knowing not and
they haven't spent enough time studying
the law to understand all of the
permanent tax reductions that are
available I mean there's thousands of
them and it's just a matter of finding
somebody who really loves taxes and can
explain it to you because that's the
other part of finding a good Tax Advisor
is you really need somebody who will sit
down and speak English and actually
explain it in simple terms I always say
that my goal in life is to make taxes
fun easy and understandable and if I can
do that I win
right and if I can do that everybody
else wins so so here's the thing the the
tax law like I said series of incentives
right and most of those incentives are
permanent tax reductions so they are
things like tax credits and they're
things like let me give you an example
let's say that you had a you were going
to go out to dinner if you don't get to
deduct that you pay tax like you
normally would but if you do you get to
reduce your tax taxes with that meal
being deducted so if you could shift it
from being non-deductible to deductible
that would be permanent because you're
never going to have to pay the
government back that money right you get
that deduction and it's yours forever
and that's way most of the tax law works
and even those things that we think of
as postponing taxes things that um we
can talk about later is like
depreciation where we're taking a
portion of the building and then if we
sell the building we could have to pick
it up in income well we can make that
permanent so there are lots of
opportunities to turn even a temporary
deduction into a permanent deduction
just by understanding the law the
challenge is that most people aren't
willing to take the time to understand
that the law is not this section and
this section this section standing alone
the law is a is a living animal it's a
living being that works together wasn't
written by accountants it was written by
attorneys and politicians and so it's
very interactive so understand
understanding the law which is what I
spend my life doing of course is really
the the key and then understanding that
look it's not out there to get you the
the IRS may be but the tax law isn't
right Congress enacted these incentives
in order to encourage you to do certain
things so once you start understanding
what those incentives are and how they
apply in your life all of a sudden taxes
get easy so if you were to think
of the five most common mist mistakes
that people make that or 10 or or you
know what what's the what are the things
that you see most where were either
doing their taxes on their own or
they're accounting where they're really
missing it well the first mistake would
be doing your taxes right that it really
would be because not hiring a
professional to do something that
Einstein said was the most complicated
thing in the world okay so it's
complicated Einstein it's really not
simple right now if you have a good tax
adviser they should be able to make it
simple at least in concept but see this
is a partnership it's a partnership
between you you and your tax adviser
there are certain things you have to do
because like I said if you're going to
change your tax you have to change your
facts I can't change those facts for you
but I can tell you what facts to change
so we have to have this constant
relationship but where it has to start
is with a long-term plan of action what
we call a tax strategy because we need
to be looking at not just today tomorrow
we even need looking at beyond your life
expectancy because what happens with
your money when you die has an impact on
how you're tax now so there's there's
nothing that we don't want to look at
and that's why that long-term tax
strategy is really the best solution
because that's a comprehensive picture
and everything we do then everything you
do during the day can be a way to save
taxes okay so I'm going to put in this
column where I'm going to start building
a column in my head of the things I need
to do long-term tax strategy let's fill
up these top five or six things where
people so number one you don't want to
like do your taxes by yourself online or
or however people doing it don't do your
taxes on your own that that's number one
you know number two is recognize that
most of the tax incentives are for
business owners and investors business
owners and actually to be more specific
professional investors so the Casual
investors doesn't get the tax benefits
the employee doesn't get the tax
benefits so the the I would say number
two is start a business I mean start a
business or start investing whether it's
in real estate or whatever you're going
to really make your life's work from an
investment standpoint you know I'm I'm
always amazed by business owners they'll
be really good at their business they'll
make all this money and then they'll
just turn the money over to somebody
that they don't even know could be an
actor for all we know right and let them
handle their money I'm going why would
you do that with you work so hard for
that money instead what about you
learning how to deal with it what about
you learning how to invest because
that's where the tax lot kicks in see if
you're a professional investor now the
tax lot gives you tax benefits that you
didn't have as a casual investor um and
it doesn't matter what type of investing
you're doing frankly you need just need
to find something that you enjoy doing
so I would say number two is that you
really have to decide okay am I going to
start a business which is so easy to do
now right I mean online businesses or
piece of cake there's virtually no
barrier to entry you can do it on your
phone so either start a business or
start investing so that would be number
two um I would say that now
interestingly enough the biggest mistake
that people make they own things
themselves so they don't use what we'd
call an entity like a corporation or a
partnership or a limited liability
company they just own it themselves and
that produces huge negative tax
consequences for example if you had a
business and you didn't have any type of
entity you would report that business on
Schedule C well Schedule C is basically
a profit and loss or an income statement
there's no balance sheet there's no
statement cash there's no other check
and balance for it so the IRS doesn't
believe you by definition you are not to
be believed because all you have is an
income statement which is e easy to
falsify okay so actually you're five
times more likely to be audited if you
have a schedule C then if you don't so
get ready your schedule C go set up the
entities this is where you're going to
use a Tax Advisor and probably an
attorney at the same time and you're
going to set up those entities so you
know how you own your assets going to
have an impact probably the biggest
impact on how much tax you pay right off
the bat um there are several tax
deductions that I these are e these are
the easy ones these are tax deductions
that people miss and mostly they miss
them because their Tax Advisor tells
them not to take take them and to me
that's just astonishing but every time
I'm in front of a crowd I typically ask
how many of you ever been told not to
take a tax deduction and then I ask him
how many of you were told not to take
the home office deduction now I'll home
off stage that's not much you know it's
a little bit of you know taxes and it's
a little bit bit of Interest I I I get
the interest anyway you know yeah I
don't get the taxes anymore but I get
the interest anyway and so it's really
not that much what they don't recognize
is that by not taking the home office
deduction you're also limiting your
automobile deduction see this is how
these things work together remember that
if you're driving a car for work that
first drive of the day is a commute not
deductible the last drive home is a
commute not deductible what if your
first drive of the day is 30 ft from
your kitchen to your home office that's
your commute and the IRS says that's
your commute now that means that that
first drive of the day that you have say
to your first property or your first
client now that's deductible so you
basically for most people they'll double
their tax deduction for their car if
they take a home office deduction and
the home office deduction is a specific
deduction that's allowed in the law I
mean they actually the IRS actually
tells you how to do it so to not to be
told don't take the home office
deduction because it's a red flag first
of all it hasn't been a red flag since
about 1997 okay so that that means that
you know and remember hearing that it's
like wait a minute you'll trigger an
audit if you exactly every everybody
says that if you do it right the Iris
will never know you have a home office
unless they audit you because there's no
place to report if you do it right
there's no place to report on the tax
return now if you have a schedule C
you're also going to report your home
office so now you've doubled up your red
flags you've got a Schedule C which is
the big red flag and you got a home
office which they're saying do we
believe you that you have you know that
your your home office is legitimate you
instead have have an entity like an S
corporation for example and all you do
is reimburse yourself for that home
office and all it says is office expense
on the tax return it doesn't say home
office anywhere that's it couldn't
trigger an audit so it could possibly
trigger an audit now if they do audit
you they will probably ask the question
but that's okay make it a legit you know
I'm everything I'm talking about you
want to do it legitimately you sit down
with your Tax Advisor you go through the
rules you follow all the rules you
document everything it's it's not that
hard I mean we've helped thous thousands
and thousands of people do this okay are
there a couple more easy give you a
couple of other ones so meals okay now
any any business owner knows that if
they go to dinner with their spouse they
are going to talk about business because
that's the way we are we are built that
way and it doesn't matter if our spouse
is involved in the business or not
involved in the business I had a I had a
my first wife was a musician still I
wanted to bounce things off her okay
second wife she's an
accountant now we're talking about
business we talk about taxes all the
time either one though that's a
legitimate business expense because
you've had a business purpose for it
you've had a business discussion about
it it's actually necessary for your
business it's helping your business and
you document it and so as long as you
meet those tests there's something
that's deductible most people don't
either they don't document it which then
it's not deductible or they don't take
it okay so meals is a big one uh you
know we want to be you know we want to
be greedy we we always say pigs are cute
and Hogs get slaughtered right so you
know make sure that it really is
legitimate business and documenting is
just writing on the back of the receipt
I was with this person did this thing
talked about that's exactly that's all
it is and and then you know what do you
do you take a picture of it right and
and you you file it right you take a
picture of it you scan it um don't keep
the receipt cuz that's going to fade and
it's going to be blank by the time the
IRS catches up with you so that's not
going to do any good so take a picture
of it they love they love documentation
that is scanned or take or pictures
another big one is travel so um you know
people travel all the time and they may
be doing business and they may not know
realize that if they spend more than
half a day and they're doing business
that can only be done in that location
then that makes the trip deductible I I
had a client years ago that he said said
Tom I'm we're traveling to New Mexico
all the time and we'd really like it to
be deductible what do I have to do and I
said well you're in you know you're in
the real estate business so you know
spend time looking at real estate and
actually do business there well here's
what's interesting so he comes back
after the very first trip and he says
says Tom can we meet I said sure he says
he's so excited he can hardly stand it
he says Tom I found a
deal says it's going to net me a million
dollars I said and I asked him I said so
is this a new deal is this something
just he says no it's been there for a
long time I just never saw it cuz I was
never looking for it so see what the
government wants us to do is be looking
for those deals I mean obviously he's
going to pay tax when he does that
development and the government's going
to get more money from the develop from
the successful development than they
ever would from than they'd ever pay in
a tax deduction for the travel so it's
good for the government the governments
are partnered I mean the reality is
we're all partners with the government
right they're taking some percentage of
our earnings every single day so we can
be a good partner or a bad partner and
they don't care which one frankly you
know they're happy to take our money or
they're happy to give us the tax benefit
if we do what they want us to do that's
great I I um just you know thinking
where you know and and I am doing this
but like we just shot a series in Italy
and I got to go to Italy and Scout that
trip before we you know went over there
and shot that trip sounds like a
horrible job it was this is a tough
really tough job a tough job but you
know it was a legitimate business you
know use of my time and and and and
money and you know it was for my company
and it was a blast of course and it
doesn't and here's the thing you don't
have to I mean you can still go out at
night and you still you know have fun
and you can go you know take a side trip
to see Venice not not a big deal right
as long as the reason that you're there
is business so what are um specifically
for entrepreneurs or investors what are
some of the best strategies that you're
you're implementing with them right now
so really what we look at is we we look
at um five areas that we're going to
look at the first one we're going to
look at deductions are they taking
advantage of all their deductions is
there anything they can do to to to
Really change what they do on a daily
basis so that more of their expenses can
be deductible that's the very first
thing we look at and that's kind of what
I call low hanging fruit okay the second
thing we do is we look at can they
generate better income so when I say
better income most people know that
capital gains are tax at a lower rate
than ordinary income well ordinary
income is tax at a lower rate than
earned income because there's no social
security taxes and then there's tax
exempt income so you can go all the way
from earned income that's taxed as high
as 60% all the way to non- taxable
income so one of the things we want to
do is look at is there any way to
convert some of your income from a high
tax rate income to a lower tax rate
income okay can for example let me take
you through a a situation let's say
you've decided that you're going to get
into real estate and you decide okay I'm
going to flip houses well flipping
houses is a business guess what earned
income well the very first thing we do
okay you're flipping houses so we're
going to take that from earned income
we're going to put you in a nest
Corporation and we're going to take away
the earned income it's now just ordinary
income so now you're not paying the
Social Security tax on it then what
we're going to do is we're going to say
well look are there any of those houses
that you like to rent out oh yeah I'd
like to rent some of those out they're
really good properties you know now
you're you're on the inside as an
investor right now you start renting
them out now you've gone from earned
income to capital gain because you're
renting it out now you go okay now in
I'm going to take depreciation but
eventually I'm going to sell that
property okay so let's turn that into
non-t taxable income by doing a like
kind exchange a 1031 exchange so now
we're not going to pay tax at all and
guess what if you hold that property
when you die if you're still holding
real estate when you die that tax
completely
disappears so you've gone from earned
income to ordinary income to capital
gain all the way to zero with the same
investment it's just a matter of
changing some of your facts now you have
to want to do that right you want to
want have to want to hold it and rent it
as opposed to flip it um but the first
one's really easy because that's just a
matter of using entity that anybody can
do that so that's the second thing we do
the third thing we do is we look at tax
brackets now I actually I actually um
was in South Africa with Mr kosaki a few
years ago and we had a a South African
chartered accountant there with us um
that we'd met previously and I I I said
the morning before we go on I said so
let me ask you a
question could you hire your kids to do
work in your business would that be
legal in South Africa she goes yeah I
guess it would I said don't they have
their own tax
she goes well they do I'm going wouldn't
that be a major tax savings she goes
that's fantastic I'm going it's it's not
that hard I mean we have a
$122,000 standard deduction in the US
every child has
one it's what I call an underperforming
asset okay because you've got tax
brackets in your children or your
elderly parents that probably aren't
being used up so why not use those low
tax brackets everybody gets them you
know um Donald Trump gets low tax
brackets right um you know Bill Gates
gets low tax brackets now he uses them
up pretty fast right but they're there
and everybody gets those brackets well I
had a client once with eight children
well that's eight sets of tax brackets
and eight standard deductions and that
we saved them literally over $100,000 in
tax every single year just by using
their tax brackets so that's another
thing to look at is you know how could I
use my tax brackets then a fourth thing
we look at is are there tax credits is
there tax exempt income are the things
that are really not taxable at all that
we can take advantage of whether it's
solar credits whether it's um credits
for Education whether it's child credits
whether it's adoption credits whether
it's work credits I mean there are all
these different credits that most people
don't even know about it's just a matter
of sitting down seeing you know what can
I do then if all else fails and we still
have tax liability we'll postpone it we
we we still want to postpone it cuz
that's still better than paying it now
but what we want to do is we want to
take those first four areas and really
focus on those and then if we can take
care of those that's typically we can
get people down to a 20% or lower tax
bracket regardless of how much money
they're making wow this you know when I
um and again this philosophy I'm I'm I'm
really trying to get it that that all
you're doing is allowing the government
to incentivize you to do what they
they want you to do and get this you
know this creates our economy they want
people to start businesses they want
people to develop um to to develop new
projects what what do you think
um the the the new Trump tax law what
what are what's the impact that's having
if any oh it's actually having a huge
impact in certain areas because there
were Big Winners and big losers the big
losers were employees we all know that
we no longer have employee business
expense deductions we got limited on our
on our tax expense we got limited on our
home mortgage interest um so employees
just got hammered they did with the
Trump tax bill who
won surprisingly enough Real Estate
Investors won now we have bonus
depreciation on real estate which means
that if you invested let's say you went
out and bought a million a duplex for a
fourplex for a million dollars okay and
you put $200,000 down your firste
deduction is likely to be $250 to
$300,000 wow even though you only put
$200,000 into it because the bank
doesn't get a tax deduction you do as
the investor so you get this huge tax
Edition the very first year it's the
only time in history that real estate
has been uh A Better Tax Benefit than
oil and gas now oil and gas is another
one oil and gas used to be that you got
an 80% deduction the very first year you
invested Ed so if you put $100,000 into
an oil and gas deal you got an 80 you
got 80% of that as a deduction which is
worth about
$32,000 now it's 100% because on top of
the oil benefits you still have
depreciation so now you have the 80%
that was the oil benefit and you have
which we call intangible drilling cost
and you have the 20% that's actually
equipment so that's deductible now too
so basically you put $100,000 in you get
a $100,000 deduction so again it's it's
a matter of looking at what does the
government want me to do and going ahead
and doing it as long as it fits your
investment strategy so we don't ever
want the tax tail to wag the dog but
I'll tell you what it's a pretty big
incentive so the big big winner was real
estate um we also have the opportunity
zone credit which is opportunity zones
which is a huge tax benefit for Real
Estate um people who want to invest in
developing areas
um another one is uh small business got
big tax benefits because they got this
20% deduction 20% of your income is now
no longer taxable if you're in business
if you're an employee 100% of your
income's taxable if you're a business
owner 80% of your income is taxable so
if that's not enough to encourage you to
be in business uh I I I don't know what
it is because to me I'd much rather be
taxed on 80% than 100% And then we have
other tax benefits like um now uh a
small business somebody who makes less
than $25 million gross a year now we
don't typically think of that as too
small of a business but you can make up
$25 million a year in gross income and
still be on the cash receipts method you
can actually if you have inventory you
can deduct your inventory when you buy
it I mean there's all sorts that that
was a huge win that nobody ever talks
about because it's kind of obscure um
but there are little nuggets like that
in the tax law um that if you understand
the tax law all of a sudden become big
uh another one is you know you could
start a c you can start a company or
even if you already have a company and
if you invest the money back into the
company after five years you can sell it
and pay no tax when you sell it okay
wait say that again so okay so start a
so let's say you've got a company okay
and we have to there's of course we got
to follow the rules we got to go through
all all the details what we're going to
do is we're going to be a C corporation
well nobody ever this is actually not a
new law what's new is now C corporations
only pay tax at 21% that's what the big
companies pay right 21% so now it makes
sense because I'm okay paying tax at 21%
I'm not paying tax at 35% like I used to
so I got this now it's okay to keep
putting my money back into the company
after five years I can sell it and
there's no capital gains
tax wow and it just goes on and on so
businesses and real estate they were the
two big Winners so I'm telling you this
is where you know everybody is or
entrepreneurs are always focused on
making more and forgetting that
sometimes you can have significant holes
in your bucket that are draining way you
know sometimes the best way to make more
money is to stop losing money that well
it it's it's actually a you know how
much you have to make how many sales you
have to have if you think if your if
your net profit is 20% Then in order to
increase your your net profit from $200
to
$220 you got to sell a lot more product
in order to get that up by $20 but in
order to if you just reduce your taxes
by $20 you've done the same thing and
this is why I always say the fastest way
to put money in your pocket is reduce
your taxes and it's actually the easiest
thing in the world I typically we start
working with a client within 3 months we
reduce their taxes by somewhere between
10 and 40% that's typical that's if
they're a business owner now if they're
not a business owner they're an employee
and they're only going to be an employee
I can do nothing for you so how much
money does somebody need to be making
annually before they should like if I'm
assuming if somebody is making $30,000 a
year a corporation having a corporation
isn't going to help them that much
what's the dividing land yeah if you're
making 30,000 a year you're probably not
paying any taxes okay that mean that's
the way the tax law works right the tax
law is is a graduated Progressive um tax
Schedule so you know but if you're
making you know $150 $200,000 a year you
got to be seriously thinking about your
tax liability because it's a it's your
probably your single biggest expense
what else do you wish that people knew
is there some you know that that that if
you could stand on a mountain top and
let people know what would it be well
what one thing I do is most people are
scared to death of taxes and
particularly the IRS right so can we do
a little test here yes all right so how
would you like to never ever have to
worry about the IRS I would love that
okay so here you go repeat after me I
will never I will never speak to speak
to the IRS the IRS there you go because
that's not your job that's my job see
it's like you have the opportunity to
put a professional in there to do that
job for you and for me IRS doesn't
bother me I I don't get nervous about
the IRS I don't get emotional about it
I'm a professional I I've got lots more
experience than any IRS auditor okay for
you it's brand new so it's a little bit
like you know you were playing
basketball one-on-one and you could hire
LeBron James wouldn't you do that and
yet people go no I'm just going to do it
myself because I'm going to save some
money well you're going to pay in just
the emotions of it you're going to pay
in the time and you're going to end up
paying a lot more tax if you don't have
a professional on your side so it's
really about building a team building a
team I think um Robert always says that
uh business is a team sport and there's
no question and when it comes to a tax
professional on your team I I just don't
think there's anybody that's going to
have a bigger impact on your financial
situation other than maybe your spouse I
think you're probably right I love what
you're doing if people want to pursue
this more you know how do they find you
or are you hiding from you got some
pretty big clients I don't hide from
anybody um so so you the very first
question you asked is how do you find
the a good tax adviser and what I found
over the years is that is the single
hardest thing for people to do that is
the number one question I get whether
I'm here or in Europe or in um Africa or
in Asia it doesn't matter that's the
number one question I'm going to get so
we decided to take that on okay so we
actually have a network of CPAs so if
you want the Easy Button you just go to
wealth ability.com the company is wealth
ability.com because it's all about your
ability to create wealth so you go to
wealth ability.com and we will at no
charge help you find a Tax Advisor that
is so great there you go hey Tom this
has been terrific thank you so much for
taking the time to talk with us
absolutely happy to do
it
your episode 6 bonus interview is with
investor Scott Stewart who has a simple
if unconventional message he says you
should ignore 401ks in mutual funds the
1% are the 1% in many cases because they
think about money and invest much
differently than we do and there's one
simple step you can take right now to
make sure your money works for you on
autopilot day and night forever
take a look and thanks for
[Music]
watching Scott thank you for being here
thanks for having me yeah looking
forward to this so tell me a little bit
about who you are and what it is that
you do and how you got there oh boy
that's a big question uh so I've always
been excited about investing since about
the age of 12 it was something that just
enthralled me that uh that idea of money
making money rather than you earning the
money for yourself and uh it was a long
journey uh I I I thought it would be a
great career for myself and so uh about
age 23 or 4 uh 1987 I started out as a
stock broker uh and went into Investment
Banking and it was interesting the the
deeper that I got into the financial
World your friends neighbors relatives
they would meet you and know what you
did for a living and everybody views you
as an expert and and the more
qualifications I got the more
designations and letters I put behind my
name the more uh series sixes or sevens
or 25s registrations that I got uh the
less I I really felt that I knew about
the marketplace and I knew a lot about
regulations and rules and how to process
transactions but I was like a lot of
people I just I wasn't I wasn't making a
lot of money and I always views that is
a little bit of a a disconnect and so uh
I I tried to figure out how I could get
out of the industry of selling people on
investments and figure out how to make
the Investments work for myself and that
was a was a long journey there was a lot
of false starts along the way um but
that was always my end goal and and
that's one of the things that I'm the
most proud of today I uh I never really
set out to to be a a rich person or
drive Ferraris or live in mansions but I
wanted to be able to support my family
family off of my own efforts off of
trading and not have to rely on a job
and I believed in investing that's why I
went into it as a career and I I I
thought that this was something that
could create Financial Independence for
not just for my clients at the time but
for me as well it wasn't happening in
either case it wasn't happening for my
clients and it certainly wasn't
happening for me and I started to feel
like you know is investing in general
just a scam or am I maybe approaching it
incorrectly and and that's what I found
is like no there's empirical evidence
that there's a lot of people getting
wealthy through investing um but they
must be doing something different than I
am and I I always thought about the
phrase uh being exceptional you know as
you look in life at a human being
whether you're talking about personal
physical spiritual mental Financial
whatever it is there's only about 1% of
the human population that we would view
as exceptional and of course the 99
percenters or the masses or the average
or the norms and and I was like well
what does it take to be exceptional and
and you you look at these people whether
it's an actor or whoever you say hey
that's an exceptional person they do
things differently than the masses
they're always the salmon that's
swimming Upstream when you know when the
rest of the world is going this way
they're all head in the different
direction I'm like well I don't really
know as an investor what I should be
doing or what I need to do to be
successful but I know what I shouldn't
do you know I know that this whole
concept of 401ks and mutual funds that's
been pushed on us uh as the solution it
it can't be the answer because
everybody's doing that and nobody I know
is wealthy nobody I know is retiring
early at 50 with more money than they
know what to do with so that was sort of
the The Epiphany that I had where I got
to go find a different approach to
investing uh and make this work for
myself so that I feel good about telling
others about you know what is this
opportunity and why are you kind of
stupid if you don't take advantage of it
so that was it was a journey so I'm
assuming the journey was not then you
started making millions of dollars
instantly and and it was great so take
us on the the learning curve if you
asked my wife she would say I'm cheap I
like to call myself Thrifty but she
calls me cheap and uh I am the
proverbial guy that will drive around
town all day long spending $7 in
gasoline to save $3 at the pump and uh
everybody told me listen you're you're
you you wouldn't figure out how to
become a doctor on your own I mean we
all understand that there's a process
and a cost to to to becoming an expert
at anything trading's no different and I
was like well I can figure it out
there's there's libraries full of free
books I'll figure this out and so I had
a lot of fault starts and I paid a heavy
tuition uh in the school of hard and Ox
a lot of fault starts uh and and blew up
several very small accounts initially
not knowing what I was doing finally
realized that I probably needed to to
hire a mentor and anybody that's good uh
at anything is expensive and I I
remember it was a lot of money for me to
come up with to hire somebody that was
quote unquote an expert uh at trading
and I had to sell a car to get enough
money to start trading again and had
this little account we did my first
trade and we made like I remember it was
like
$22 and uh he was estatic he was a he's
like look at that that's amazing what a
good job you and I'm just like it's 22
bucks he's like and I always remember
this he said you need to trade with the
intent to trade well if you you trade
well if you play the game correctly the
financial results will follow but if
you're trading because you need a
paycheck you're trading because you need
x amount to make the mortgage payment
next week you're going to have a tough
go at it so I've always remembered that
you know I want to trade technically
correct I want to do the right things in
the right ways the money will follow and
so it did you know but yeah I wasn't
Rich overnight you know the next trade
was $32 then $50 then $100 and you start
getting to that point and I think it's
different for everybody depending on
your lifestyle you know how much you
need to to to keep a roof over your head
on a monthly basis but when you start
getting to a couple thousand a month
you're like wow this is real like this
could really allow me to take care of my
family uh and and that was the big boom
for me it was about 2,000 a month where
I'm like I could really turn this into
something powerful uh and then you put
more effort into it and you get better
results with more effort and it was a
process but it is a process
and uh I think no matter what we say as
individuals we all are enor with that
get-rich quick theme uh you know
everybody wants to be a million tomorrow
and it's just it's not how it works
there's there's a tremendous opportunity
in the market but it isn't a get-rich
concept or strategy it does take time it
takes effort and it takes repetition um
it takes a long time to to knock down a
100 or 200 or 300 practice trades to the
point that you feel comfort able doing
something and you know it's like
anything in life you got to put in the
effort so what kind of training do you
do now so there's been an evolution and
the evolution continues it it it just
continues and continues I started like
most people start with Buy and Hold You
know the old Mantra you buy low you sell
High go find a good asset no matter what
it is at a low price buy it hold on to
it at some point it's going to be worth
more you sell it you pocket the
difference and as I did that I'm like
I'm doing everything that they tell me
to do
the wealth is not coming what's going
wrong and I realized that I needed to
shift my focus from trying to build my
net worth to trying to focus on cash
flow I was so net worth oriented every
year I would look at my net worth stat
ah my net Worth's up my net Worth's you
can't feed your family on net worth uh I
would rather have a zero net worth and
have something that's creating 30 or
$40,000 a month of of cash flow for me
to live on and so I I I re oriented my
trading a little bit uh and I learned
options options are a way to control
assets without actually having to own
those assets it's more of a professional
approach I believe in the marketplace um
you know upfront going into a trade what
your max profit is what your max risk is
so you it allows you to approach it from
a professional standpoint uh and then
from options I've gravitated into
Futures and Forex and there's all
different venues to that as well one of
my bigger frustrations right now as a
full-time Trader is people ask me all
the time well you know what's the best
trade what's your favorite trade I'm
like well my favorite trade is probably
not even going to be workable for you
because I don't have a day job and I can
sit at my computer all day long and push
buttons and trade uh you probably have a
life and even if you have the ability to
sit in front of your computer all day
long you may not want to do that this
may not be your passion so it is a
process of finding what works best for
individuals but it's it's interesting to
me you know I'm 53 years old I've been
at this for about 35 years now I'm still
learning like I'm still growing in terms
of understanding opportunities that the
market presents and it's such a dynamic
process so I I I still learn new
Concepts and strategies today so let's
let's talk about the the basics of
options you know a lot of people when
they hear that you option so you can
lose all your money and they they you
shy away from
and most people probably should shy away
from it but I know that there's a lot of
people that we're talking to that would
enjoy taking an active role in managing
their money so H that walk us through
options the and you also don't seem like
a real high risk taker well just as you
talk about being Frugal and so so I I I
think your question is sort of a
two-part question it's number one you
know what is this risk component to it
and then how complicated are options
really so the risk component I I take
Umbridge that's a that's a big fancy $6
word but I take Umbridge with the fact
that people say
XYZ investment whatever it is
Commodities Futures options that's
risky I would uh throw out there that
there is no risk in any investment of
any kind risk is not innate it does not
exist inside of Investments these are
innate objects they're just Commodities
the risk comes from what you and I as
individuals do with that investment how
we approach it whether we manage it or
not whether we just throw money in and
hope for the best we as individuals are
the ones that decide what the risk
inside of an investment is and and
options are a perfect example of that I
can ask you right up front what do you
got to work with $1,000 do you tell me
how much of that would you be willing to
risk everybody's different right some
people say I'll roll it all some people
would say man I I wouldn't sleep well at
night if I lost a hundred bucks of it
you know it's my life savings fine we
can build a trade with that thousand
dollar that only puts 100 of it at risk
but you decide the risk so that's a big
paradigm shift for a lot of people that
we can decide what risk we want to be
involved in the market doesn't decide
that for us and then with options you
know it's like anything uh whatever you
do for a career there's probably some
buzzword that you use in your industry
that maybe other people uh don't
necessarily understand what you're
talking about I always like this saying
I really believe this to be true in life
there's very few things that are hard or
difficult I really believe that it's
just everything at some point in life is
new and and when you're confronted with
something that's new it can seem
overwhelming and really really
complicated I think uh it was Warren
Buffett that said that as human beings
we take things of Great Value and we
purposely over complicate them because
if it if if it's of tremendous value to
us it must be complicated right lawyers
and doctors are great at this they're
fantastic at this because if a lawyer
would use plain English we could do what
they do for ourselves I went to the
doctor a while ago I had a checkup and
he said well you got this guy I'm like
can you know I don't understand any of
the words that you're using please and
and you know that there's a word in the
English language that I would understand
that means the just speak to me like a
normal person right but we purposely
overco complicate things and that
happens with options as well the the
great thing that we have with trading is
that we can paper trade we can virtual
trade we can do real trades in the real
Market with real prices and real real
real results real profit and losses but
with fake money and so we can develop
pretty high levels of Competency with
options trading strategies before you
ever have to put any real money at risk
um and and so again again it's the first
step is always the hardest uh but i'
like to say that it's not complicated
it's just new it's just something that
you have not done before well and you
have um that reputation that that we
have some mutual friends and and and
what I heard about you is that you're
really great at taking complex
strategies and making them simple so
almost the inverse of the doctor and
lawyer is like making it so people can
understand it so
let's just stay on options for a minute
and then we can we can go what um so I'm
I'm getting a sense the thing that that
you suggest to people is practice paper
trade in the real Market uh for a while
to really
get one of the things that keeps coming
up from this is education it's like
people need if you're going to do this
with your money you probably need to
figure out how to get some education so
with that as a platform walk somebody
through you know how you work with
somebody that wants to trade options and
is looking to do what you're doing well
the first step is do you are you
interested in more education in
self-education it's I saw a USA a poll a
while ago it's been a few years ago now
but they asked the question they did a
poll what is the age that the average
human being stops learning at and the
answer was 16 years old ouch and if you
have a teenager at home you already know
that that was the answer because my I
got a 15-year-old son at home right now
and the only thing I hear from him most
of the time is I know Dad I know because
that is you don't you know everything
right and uh so I ask uh students a lot
of times I'm like you know do you feel
like you are a objective openminded
individual and everybody says well of
course I am and I call them to their
face a bold-faced liar because as grown
adults we've all developed biases and
Prejudice and belief systems even if
you've never invested in your life you
have a preconceived idea about what's
what right and wrong what's the good
things what are the bad things and so
it's hard you know as we become grown
adults we've all had successes in our
careers or lives and developed
competencies in one form and it's hard
to say hey this is a new area I'm coming
in just like a child with an open mind
saying hey teach me show me what to do
and if you can get there as a human
being that's step one step two is saying
yeah I crave that additional knowledge I
crave that growth I was of the mindset
that man I I I I didn't really enjoy
High School I really didn't enjoy
college and finally when you're done
you're like well I'm done I don't ever
need to do that again and if you can
develop that mindset that I want to grow
as a human being I want to gain
additional knowledge then that's step
two step three is starting with very
very basic trade so we start with very
small very simple trades and we say
practice that for 10 times and the big
thing is a Hands-On coaching approach
that's the big
thing
there's libraries full of books and and
if if we could figure out how to gain
competency through Reading I'd just give
you the book and say good luck you're
set for life it's not how it
works uh colleges have built a a
billion-dollar industry on the fact that
you need to sit in front of a professor
in a live format we can't just hand out
books and so the real thing comes with
that hands- on approach and the first
time anybody does anything new the first
time anybody does a trade it's very
similar Fe back they're like I I I I
don't know what to do push that button
right there I don't know what that
button does I didn't ask you if you know
I said just push it okay and then you
see the result and they say yeah I see
the result but I don't know how I got it
great let's do it again what button do
you push oh I know what button to push
now I still don't know what it does
nobody asked you just push it and by the
fourth or fifth time you're like I kind
of understand this but it does take uh
you know there's two ways to learn
things in life there's an academic
approach and then there's a Hands-On
approach approach and most of the things
that we learn in life is academics we we
sit in classrooms we listen to lectures
we read books we watch videos you've got
to have an hand hands-on experience with
trading you you you can't watch videos
all day long you can't read books you
have to have somebody that can say hey
do this right here let me show you I'll
put your finger on the button if we have
to so that's the big distinction that's
where I see a lot of people fail is they
they've got every book in the world on
trading and they're no closer to
actually doing real successful trades so
how do how do you um how do you make
money from like an options trade
literally what's the mechanics of so one
of the big components in the stock
market is this underlying knowledge that
a lot of people don't I think they
understand but they don't process and
that's the fact that the market is a
zero sum game and zero sum is just a
real fancy way of saying for one person
to win one must lose so I always love it
when the market crashes we have a big
down today and CNBC always puts the same
headline on you know $1.2 trillion was
lost in the market today and I always
chuckle and think man we should we
should hire somebody to go look for that
I mean where did it go you know nothing
was lost in the market money doesn't
disappear it just exchanged hands
conversely if you make a $100 today that
didn't just appear out of thin air
somebody had to lose that $100 for it to
appear in your pocket so it is a zero
sum game for one to win one must lose
well the natural inclination that we're
all just raised with is to buy assets
that's the key we need to buy assets we
need to buy stock we need to be buying
real estate we need to buy options to
profit from those positions we take the
opposite side of that trade so if we
understand that for every buyer there
must be a seller for every seller there
must be a buyer we want to be the seller
of those options because we know
historically this is from the OCC the
options Clearing Corporation and we know
that over time about 83% of all options
that are purchased they lose money on
those so if I know that
beforehand what side of the trade you
want to be on I want to be the guy
that's selling you the options if you
think you're going to make money off of
it good luck I hope you I wish you I
wish you well but I know that 83% of the
time you're going to lose money and
conversely 83% of the time I should make
money so we take the other side of the
trade we sell options and we receive
income upfront from that trade so I can
tell you when I put a sell together with
an option position what the maximum
profit of that trade is going to be and
I can tell you when it'll appear in my
account that's pretty important
especially as a full-time Trader because
I got a budget like everybody else I got
a mortgage I need to know what my income
potential looks like in a month to be
able to feed my family and pay my bills
so um and is are the majority of your
trades in options most of them are in
options because it allows me to control
the the risk and the reward I know what
the potential return is before I get
into the trade I know what the risk is
before I get into the trade I'm the one
that sets those parameters so if I'm I'm
unhappy with the result of a trade it's
not the Market's fault it's my fault and
then in addition to that it allows me a
greater window of profit potential you
can sell options in a way in a structure
that can allow you to make money whether
the market goes up down or stays the
same now that sounds crazy if you don't
understand options how can you make
money regardless of what the market does
but it's just called bracketing it's
saying hey I don't really know where the
Market's going today or tomorrow but I
feel comfortable that it will stay
within a certain specified range and as
long as it does that I'm going to
capture an income from that so it's
maybe you know analogy Wise It's the
difference between TR trying to throw
darts and hit a a bullseye versus just
trying to hit the broadside of a barn
it's easier to hit the broadside of the
barn it's an easier trade it's a higher
price probability of success trade so so
during the course of a day you're you're
you know you're active you're involved
you're trading how long are these
options you know are you in and out of
them in a very short period of time or
are you holding you know selling them
and waiting them out right so one of the
one of the things that I love about
trading it's incredibly flexible it in
terms of being able to make money with
options it's a very flexible trading
vehicle in that you can tailor the
duration or the time frame of these
trades to whatever you have in terms of
Lifestyle so I I I've met a lot of
people that are like listen I I have a
busy life I have a full-time job I'm
working 70 hours a week or maybe I have
the time but I I'm not inclined to be
sitting in front of my computer all day
long we can put on 30 40 50 60-day
trades these are trades that you maybe
just need to pop in and check maybe once
every 3 or four days just to see what
it's doing uh I have the luxury now now
of not having to go to a full-time job I
love trading so I sit in front of my
computer all day long uh and so I'm
doing a lot of shorter term trades too
as as short as maybe one or two hours
but the flexibility is there to build a
system that customizes or works for you
and I think that's one of the challenges
uh that's one of the great things about
having that education because everybody
comes in with the same thought look just
tell me what the best trade is just tell
me what the best way to and there is no
best way it depends on your risk param
the amount of money that you have to
trade with and really how much time do
you want to put into this uh I I say I
don't have a full-time job I really do
it's trading I I'm at my computer from
7:30 in the morning until 2: in the
afternoon Mountain Time trading uh my
accounts What could somebody I want to
set a goal for somebody like what what's
this worth you know what could somebody
reasonably expect if they're willing to
invest the time in themselves and the
education and and they think like you
know yeah I would enjoy sitting and and
trading all day yeah what what's a
reasonable expectation of what they
could do in terms of in so so rate of
return how much can I make that's always
the first question of course it's the
hardest one to answer there's no
guarantees in life there are certainly
no guarantees in trading but we know
what the potential of options trades are
and that's where we start with and so
it's interesting uh in our kosaki cash
flow program we're just now uh this week
we are coming this Friday to the close
of our one-year anniversary with that
program and uh we've done over 200
trades over the last year inside of that
program um it's a sophisticated trade
it's called an iron Condor but it's
interesting I think we and again I don't
have the final numbers yet because we
haven't quite finished but I'm thinking
that we're going to come in somewhere
around 95% success rate so in 200 trades
95% of those were winners for us and we
should clock in somewhere around 40 or
50% for the year annualized rate of
return now one of the things that I
always think about is the rule of 72
it's it's it's a real easy simple back
of the napkin computation that you can
do you just simply take the interest
rate that you're earning you divide it
into the number 72 it'll tell you how
long it takes you to double your account
value so if you're earning 7.2% a year
it's going to take you 10 years to ear
to ear that money back if you're earning
10% a year it will take 7.2 years years
to double your account value well at 24%
a year your money doubles every 3 years
at 36% a year your money doubles every
two years with that compounding effect
so you only you only have to double
$7,000 seven times to turn it into a
million dollars and one of the things
that I see with a lot of people is they
say boy I can I can see how this would
be great for me if I had a million
dollars to go start this today but I
don't I don't have any money and I
always like to say if you had a million
you wouldn't need it you should be on
the beach right now somewhere right it
is the fact that you don't have a
million that means that you really do
need this it it's interesting people ask
uh you know how how much money do I need
to start with and I'm like you're going
to start with whatever you have that's
where you start I don't know if you have
a million or you have a thousand but
that's where we start the key is just to
get started get that compounding effect
taking place and then we can sort of
figure that cross point you know on the
graph of what's it going to take you is
it going to take you 15 years until you
can replace your income from your day
job or is it going to take you 15 months
I don't know it depends on the amount
but the key is to start and uh our goal
we've surpassed our goal tremendously
this year but if we can make 3% a month
36% a year and double an account size
every two years it doesn't really matter
how little you start with it's enough to
get you to your ultimate goal the
question is just how long would that
process take but I think that's the
light of at the end of the tunnel for a
lot of people uh you look at how much
you think you need in retirement and
where you're at now people just get
depressed they're like that's not going
to happen there's no way I'm going to
get there well we can do one of two
things right you can figure out how to
bring in three or four times as much
money as you're currently earning so
that you can get to that
goal or we can just figure out how to
make better rates of return and and it
sounds crazy as you get started that
mindset that Paradigm Shift of hey we're
trying to build trade
that have the potential to make in one
month the return that most people would
be happy with in one year but that's the
Dynamics that's the the the the key of
options trading and the strategies that
we
employ so you mentioned earlier Forex
right and I know nothing about Forex you
know how active are you in that what's
the so that comes back really to your
personality and that question that
people always ask is well what's the
best best thing to trade you know and
there's no right answer it depends a lot
on your lifestyle and your risk
propensities and your personalities but
I love Forex Forex is currency trading
or what is sometimes referred to as
pairs trading but it is a dynamic Market
there's a lot of Leverage there and it's
a 24hour a day Market starts up on
Sunday evening and then it just keeps
going until Friday afternoon 24 hours a
day and so there there is a dynamic
there I thought I was a very disciplined
person until I started trading Forex and
then you you'd get up at 2:00 in the
morning to go to the bathroom and then
on the way back to bed you'd be like I'm
I'm just going to check the markets just
for a second then before I knew it it
was like 6:40 in the morning my wife's
yelling at me to get the kids up for
school and I'm like I'm going back to
bed you know and then I'd wake up at
noon and she's like what are you doing
with your life so it takes some
discipline to trade it but when you have
the time to do it Leverage is like Risk
if we can control the risk the more
leverage we can have the better off we
can be you can do very small trades you
can do $25 trades in Forex and have a a
a real actual decent rate of return so
in terms of potential there's probably
nothing close to Forex but it's not
always where everybody starts it's a a
24-hour market so are the are the
skills that you use in your regular
options trading are they directly
applicable for the X Market absolutely
yeah so so one of the big epiphanies
that I had that was that was very
helpful for me in in just my education
process was this idea or this concept of
differentiating between
underlyings the assets that you happen
to be trading and strategies and I
always thought that the question was
well what's the underline what should I
trade should I trade Forex should I
trade Futures should I trade Commodities
should I trade options or stocks one's
got to be better than another right and
the real answer is it's not really about
the underlying asset that you trade it's
about the strategy that you employ on
that asset and once you get a solid
strategy down it doesn't really matter
if you're trading oil or precious metals
or cattle or options or stocks it's the
strategy that is going to make you
successful not the accet actual asset
that you're trading can you give us an
example of a strategy so the real key
that we like to use is this iron Condor
trade and the iron Condor trade is a is
a simple probability trade it simply
says that I'm humble enough uh to admit
that I don't know what the market is
going to do tomorrow let alone next week
or next month and so rather than trying
to pick a direction rather than trying
to say I think this is going to go up
I'm going to buy it or I think it's
going to go down I'm going to short it
we do what's called an iron Condor using
options and that's where we set up
parameters we say I don't know where
this thing's going but I can look at
tools mathematical tools like standard
deviation and those kinds of things will
tell us probabilities and say listen
this is where that asset's at today we
don't know if it's going up or down but
we do know that there's a certain
probability or a statistical chance that
it will stay within this defined range
over this specified time and we can
Define that probability it could be 80%
it could be 95% and that's the trade
that we build so again I love this
concept of thinking like a like a an
exceptional person a one Center if you
will and the the phrase that I always
love is sometimes the more educated you
get the more uneducated you sound to the
99 percenters out there you know people
say well what are you trading well I'm
trading Amazon I'm trading Apple you
know oh what do so you think it's going
up I I don't know I have no idea well
you think it's going down clueless no
idea what it's going to do but I do have
a high confidence level that it's going
to stay in a certain range over a
specified time frame and the way I've
structured this options trade it can go
up it can go down it can stay the same
but as long as it stays in that range
I'm going to profit from that trade and
I know what the profit is UPF front
before I even do the trade and that's
critical that's critical so right now
tell me what uh what's coming for you
what's the next step what are you most
excited
about there's a lot there's a lot that's
coming down the pike and and and I'm
really excited about it it's uh it's
been a long time coming for me I feel
really really blessed to have had the
opportunity to work with a lot of the
individuals that are involved with
Paradigm press I I really believe that
we have one of the largest brain trusts
Mastermind groups here that's ever been
assembled anywhere in terms of investing
prowess there's some amazing amazing
individuals here in this Collective and
so the the idea
is how do we get all that knowledge and
that wealth of information simplified
distilled and out to new individuals and
so we've got a couple of really exciting
things coming we've got one with Grant
Cardone that is a real estate product
that is how do you make money off of
real estate in the stock market where
with a push of a button you can get in
and out of your real estate Investments
and maybe have the opportunity to make
five to 10 times the cash flow potential
off of that real estate as you would if
you owned an actual rental property wow
so it's pretty exciting there's a lot of
cool things coming our way I I love the
whole concept that and you know I'm I'm
a big Robert kosaki fan and I'm I love
his focus on cash flow I love what you
guys are doing with it um I think this
is this is the way you direct direct ly
improve people's lives is um helping
them increase the amount of money they
have available to them I do I I I I have
I have loved and I am very appreciative
of the opportunity that I have to be
involved in this process because most of
my life I've been a Trader I I sit alone
at home in front of a laptop and there's
not a lot of social satisfaction that
comes with that and it's so exciting to
see people who have been a part of
Robert kiyosaki's cash flow program and
they come up to us and they're like you
changed my life this process literally
changed my path in life and you've
changed my whole financial future it's
like okay I'm not a doctor I'm not out
saving lives every day that's about as
close as it's going to get for me you
know thank you doesn't get any better
than that that keeps me going into
tomorrow thank you so much so yeah it's
it's a it's a tremendously gratifying
thing to take people from Financial
illiteracy to literacy and have them
watch their eyes open and see what the
real potential is because I think we
have that wonderment as a kid you know
and then we grow from adolescence to
adulthood and we just get in these ruts
in life and it's the water cooler
experience every week at work you know
uh how' your weekend go uh same old same
old how about you yeah same thing all
right see you next week you know and
just to see that wonderment come back to
grown adults and say wow I I can do
whatever I want financially and if I can
do whatever I want financially I can do
whatever I want in any other aspect of
my life too that's right yeah Scott good
for you thank you so much thank you for
having me I appreciate it to see the
next episode in the wealth breakthrough
series check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there the
biggest thing going on in the world
right now is that in particular you know
is thatt a good thing or a bad thing
well it depends what you do with the
money if you borrow money and you can
invest it